bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur Public Sénat après avoir entendu les
ministres tobira et bertinoti mardi et
hier Dominique budis le Défenseur des
droits la commission des Lois du Sénat
poursuit ce matin ses auditions sur le
mariage pour tous elle entend des
représentants des professions juridiques
qui interviennent auprès des familles
comme les notaires par exemple mais
également le président du Conseil
national d'accès aux origines
personnelles a noté que l'examen du
projet de loi ouvrant le mariage aux
personnes de même sexe sera finalement
examiné par les sénateurs en séance
publique à partir du 4 avril prochain
tout de suite donc sans plus tarder ces
auditions bonne matin à
tous mes chers
collègues nous allons
commc pratiquement à l'heure car la
matinée sera longue mais en même temps
elle sera comme passionnante j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire hier à la Conférence
des
Présidents que nous avions procédé à
déjà 40 ou 50 heur d'audition je ne sais
plus en prenant toujours le temps
nécessaire de manière à ce qu'elle
fusent instructive et en même temps à ce
qu'elle se déroulasse dans un clim
particulièrement serein et cela est
précieux mesdames et messieurs
donc nous avons l'honneur d'accueillir
Monsieur Jean darad président du Conseil
supérieur du notariat Monsieur Jacques
combré président de la section famille
de l'Institut d'études juridiques et
Madame Christine Mandelli
administrateur ou administratrice comme
elle voudra chargé j'ai des relations
avec les
institutions donc monsieur le
Président je vais d'abord vous donner la
parole pour que vous puissiez peut-être
dans en un quart d'heure 20 minutes
comme vous le souhaiterez nous faire
part de vos
appréciations et de vos remarques sur ce
projet de
loi portant sur le mariage des couples
de personnes de même sexe après quoi je
donnerai la parole à Jean-Pierre Michel
qui présidera la suite de la séance je
serai sans doute obligé de partir avant
la fin de ce même de la présente
audition et je vous prie de m'en excuser
mais ce sera un
bonheur pour vous d'être présidé par
Jean-Pierre Michel comme toujours
d'ailleurs parce que je dois aller à une
réunion stratégique et vous savez bien
que les réunions stratégiques il vaut
mieux pour ne pas les manquer en même
même si j'aurais dé plaisirs de ne pas
entendre toute la matinée mais comme
tout est enregistré que tout est filmé
de toute façon on ne perd aucune ligne
et je donnerai aussi la parole et
retranscr et retranscrit grâce au
service du contrendu analytique que nous
ne saons trop
remercier intégral aussi et du
contterenduit intégral aussi bah oui
puisque nous
avons bon alors je remercie les deux
services qui travaillent main dans la
main et alors nous donnerons aussi la
parole à Madame Michel Menier rapporteur
pour la commission des affaires sociales
puis à monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le Président
l'honneur est pour nous et merci de
votre accueil et je vais vous présenter
un un propos liminaire et ensuite je
donnerai la parole à mon confrère et ami
Jacques Combray qui est comme vous
l'avez souligné spécialiste plus
particulièrement spécialiste de ces
questions alors en en propos liminire je
souhaiteraiis dire que les notaires sont
effectivement au service de leurs
clients et de de ce fait établisse déjà
un certain nombre d'actes pour les
couples
homosexuels notamment évidemment dans le
cadre de la mise en œuvre des Pax pour
garantir la sécurité de leurs
engagements mais aussi nous avons
l'habitude de traiter avec des clients
qui sont mariés des clients de même sexe
qui sont mariés puisque le mariage entre
personnes du même sexe existe dans un
certain nombre d'États notamment de de
l'Union européenne et que bien il arrive
qu'un un couple de personnes de même
sexe marié à l'étranger achète un bien
immobilier en France ou décède et sa
succession fait contient des biens
immobiliers en France donc nous avons la
pratique déjà de du mariage homosexuel
dans notre pratique quotidienne cela dit
nous sommes confrontés souvent à des
situations que la loi ne règle pas et
notre expérience nous conduit à
permettent d'attirer l'attention du
législateur sur les effets juridiques
des dispositions de la loi lorsque
précisément elles sont incomplètes ou
imprécises en effet l'ouverture du
mariage aux personnes de même sexe ne se
résume pas à l'ouverture de la cérémonie
du mariage ou à mettre en cohérence le
vocabulaire entre mari et femme époux
épouse Père-Mère parents il y a d'autres
conséquences notamment sur le droit de
l'affiliation et sur le droit de la
famille en général
alors face à ces bouleversements il est
nécessaire d'éviter toute précipitation
et de privilégier la concertation afin
de mieux évaluer les enjeux de la
réforme preuve en est la loi instaurant
le Pax en
1999 ce texte était issu de débat
passionnés mais cloisonnés entre les
partisans du pour et les partisans du
contre et ce texte avait conservé
lesestigmat de cette désorganisation de
sorte que euh il avait fallu refaire la
loi en 2006 aujourd'hui le texte est
jugé
cohérent les statistiques doivent être
aussi pris en compte ainsi à l'étranger
dans les pays qui autorisent le mariage
entre personnes du même sexe le nombre
de ces mariages représente entre 1,9 %
c'est la statistique actuelle au
Pays-Bas et 5,1 % c'est la statistique
en Belgique en France les statistiques
font état de
251654 mariag en 2010 et de
205558 paxes dont 9143 paxes conclus
entre personnes de même sexe donc ceci
fait un total de
448069 unions mariage et paxe compris
entre personnes de sexe opposé pour
9143 Pax de personnes de même sexe ce
qui représente 2 % des unions mariage et
Pax confondu donc le mariage ne va pas
concerner qu'une catégorie de citoyens
il va consid concerernit l'ensemble des
citoyens et donc il faut également tenir
compte de ces de ces
statistiques voilà j'en ai terminé pour
mon propos liminaire et nous nous vous
ferons un exposé sur les
conséquences à nos yeux de l'ouverture
du mariage aux personnes du même sexe
sur six dans six points sur six points
particuliers tout d'abord sur le mariage
et la conjugalité
ensuite sur la terminologie juridique
ensuite sur le droit de l'adoption
puis sur le droit au
nom puis sur l'obligation alimentaire et
enfin les conséquences en droit
international privé voilà donc je vais
demander à à Jacques Combray euh tout de
suite donc de nous indiquer les
conséquences sur le mariage et la
conjugalité merci monsieur le Président
euh ici notre regard de de praticien
euh il est il part d'un
un principe à nos yeux essentiels et qui
devrait amener sans doute une réflexion
à terme sur le le mariage civil c'est
que il est essentiel que les couples
tous les couples y compris donc ceux qui
feront le choix lorsqu'ils sont de même
sexe de se marier soit prévenu des
conséquences du mariage du régime
matrimonial des suites éventuellement
pendant le mariage de la fin du mariage
avec le
divorce notre regard à nous c'est qu'au
quel que soit le couple qu'il soit
hétérosexuel qu'il soit
homosexuel c'est qu'ils ignorent les
règles qu'ils confondent les effet
euh il est curieux qu'aujourd'hui on
discute de ce texte et d'un d'une
revendication dans le casadre d'une
évolution de la société et en même temps
que ceux qui ont le choix de pouvoir se
marier soit aussi peu nombreux à se
marier bien clair qu'aujourd'hui le le
nombre de mariages si civil entre
personnes de sexe différents Stein
régress enfin en tout cas on est à un
niveau d'étiage qui n'est pas très élevé
alors ça doit poser question pour quelle
raison ceux qui peuvent ne ne se marient
pas suffisamment il y a peut-être donc
une réflexion sur la revalorisation du
mariage civil c'est pas dans ce projet
de loi mais puisqu'il y aura derrière
une une réflexion sur un projet de loi
famille ce mariage qui est à
différencier du Pax qui est à ci du
concubinage aujourd'hui je crois que les
trois les trois formes d'union se
retrouvent dans nos citoyens mais il y a
il y a des mélanges le mélange dans la
terminologie je donne souvent l'exemple
vous avez trois couples autour d'une
table je vais penser à mes enfants un
couple concubin un couple paxé un couple
marié à table on voit pas la différence
dans le langage courant on voit pas la
différence mon fils va me dire je vais
déjeuner chez ma belle-mère je dis non
tu vas déjeuner chez la mère de ta
copine je veux dire que l'expression et
c'est pas un reproche je veux dire que
c'est naturel et nous faisons tous
pareil on va parler du beau frère quand
on parle du frère du copain donc nos
citoyens ne sont pas des juristes
avertis nos citoyens ne voient pas
toujours la différence il le voi quand
il y a une catastrophe c'est quand on
vient voir pour un déessès et qu'on
découvre qu'il y aura pas de retraite de
réversion qu'on découvre qu'il y a pas
de droit successorau et cetera et cetera
donc je crois que la réflexion sur ce
mariage entre personnes de même sexe
devrait être une opportunité dans les
mois à venir pour réfléchir à une
véritable revalorisation du mariage
civil très rapidement une autre remarque
à propos des effets des conséquences
donc de de cette réforme notamment en
matière de pension de réversion j'y ai
fait allusion il y a un instant il est
clair que euh euh on va ouvrir le droit
à la pension de réversion ce qui est
normal dès lors que tous les coupes
mariés seront traités de la même manière
mais on peut arriver à des situations
paradoxales salle et je vais donner deux
exemples le premier et qui est justement
pour les couples baxés je ne dis pas
qu'il faut ouvrir le la retraite de
réversion demain au aux personnes paxées
mais c'est vrai qu'il y a beaucoup de
couples qui sont paxés et qui ne se
rendent pas compte que ce paxe ne leur
ouvre pas droit à la retraite de
réversion alors qu'ils vont avoir une
forme d'union ils vont avoir des enfants
ils vont construire un projet commun et
ils vont pas toujours faire attention à
ça alors je ne dis pas qu'on peut qu'il
faut ouvrir je dis pas que le budget est
un peu mais ça pose question deuxème une
question c'est que le droit à la
retraite de réversion par exemple est
sans considération du nombre d'enfants
ou autres donc imaginons demain une
situation ma fois tout à fait classique
d'un couple hétérosexuel quiit trois
enfants puis un divorce et l'un des deux
membres du couple se remari avec une
personne de même sexe première union
dure 15 ans 2è union dure 15 ans le
décès survient et donc le droit à la
retraite de réversion va être acquis au
nom nombre d'années de mariage et
peut-être que un ex-cjoint qui a élevé
trois enfants aura la même chose qu'un
autre conjoint qui n'en aura pas élevé
c'est pas une question de d'étérro ou
d'homosexualité c'est pas du tout ça
c'est tous les effets sur l'ensemble des
couples de cette réforme qui sans doute
devrait mériter réflexion là encore il
ne s'agit pas de dire il faut traiter ça
dans le texte on va surtout pas
perturber quelque chose qui est
important mais de dire ben voilà ça doit
ouvrir des pistes pour l'avenir de
réflexion sur ces sujetsl
euh deuxè question oui donc sur le
deuxème point les conséquences sur la
terminologie alors sur la terminologie
le texte a a beaucoup évolué en première
lecture à l'Assemblée nationale et à nos
yeux a évolué dans le bon sens on sent
est clair que la profession notariale
est favorable au au texte tel qu'il a
été adopté en première lecture
c'est-à-dire en évitant de trop
perturber notre architecture classique
du Code civil qui concerne erve bien la
notion de père et mère le président
tarad a parlé des statistiques tout à
l'heure si demain nous nous sommes dans
la moyenne des pays européen avec un
taux de mariage de personnes de même
sexe de 2 % ça veut dire qu'il y a 98 %
de couple hétérosexuel en gardant
l'architecture du Code civil telle
qu'elle est à la fois on concilie ce qui
représente la majorité des situations et
en même temps
donc la prise en compte de de de de
couple le de personnes de même sexe donc
ça nous convient euh je crois que sans
sans chercher à se mettre en valeur je
crois que nous avons bien travaillé avec
la commission des lois à l'Assemblée
nationale on a échangé essayé d'avancer
pour que
cette évolution soit soit soit soit
prise en compte donc ça nous ça nous
convient de la même manière que euh nous
considérons comme bien fonderé
l'exclusion du champ d'application de
l'article 61 des dispositions du titre 7
relative à l'affiliation je crois que la
rédaction est bonne alors on a
simplement une remarque de forme qu'on
soumet à votre appréciation c'est le le
positionnement de donc de dans l'article
4 du projet de loi de de la de cette
nouvelle disposition puisqu'on l'a mise
à pris l'article 6 première partie toute
la partie qui qui est préalable à notre
Code civil donc tout ce qui est la
publication des fait l'application de la
loi en général donc tout en tête du
livre premier et on l'a mis avant
l'article 7 du Code civil sur l'exercice
des droits civils est-ce que c'est
vraiment le bon positionnement
c'est-à-dire un endroit du Code civil où
on affirme quelques grands principes
est-ce que ça situerait peut-être pas
mieux à la fin de de de de de de des
articles préliminaires du Titre 1 des
droits civils c'està-dire entre les
articles 7 et 15 et peut-être après le
15 voilà c'est peut-être un un un une
question de présentation ça trouverait
sans doute un petit peu mieux sa place
voilà euh deuxè
modification donc sur la terminologie
c'est l'article 4 B du du projet de loi
où donc tel qu'il a été voté on indique
que l'ensemble des dispositions
législative en vigueur à l'exception des
dispositions civiles s'appliqueent
actuellement également pardon au
conjoints de même sexe et cetera il nous
semble là que peut-être ce ce texte ça
cette rédaction est peut-être un peu
ambigue un peu lacunaire parce que
l'expression l'ensemble des dispositions
législatives en vigueur laisse entendre
par exemple que les conjoints de même
sexe peuvent prétendre au mêmes droits
et obligations que les conjoints de sexe
différents notamment pour cette fameuse
PMA qui a déjà donné lieu à la
discussion alors effectivement quand on
voit l'exposé sommaire de l'amendement
pour comprendre on comprend que la
disposition ne s'appliquera pas au titre
4 du livre 1er de la 2è partie du code
de la santé publique relatif à la PMA
dans lequel on fait référence à l'homme
et la femme en RA on de leur sexe et non
au mari et à la femme comme le prévoit
l'article 410 mais on soumet à la
réflexion donc de des sénateurs que dans
un souci peut-être de lisibilité de
meilleure compréhension du texte il nous
semble que les dispositions relatives à
l'association méicalement à procréation
pour être expressément exclus en tout
cas c'est une suggestion et donc que
l'on doiv raisonner à contrario par une
analyse de l'article pour conclure que
la PMA est bien exclue voilà c'est une
suggestion que nous faisons aussi sur la
terminologie alors trème type de
conséquence et là plus plus importante à
nos yeux sur le droit de l'adoption
voilà donc ici donc il y a des points
importants dans dans la
réforme qu'il faut qu'il faut qu'il faut
intégrer je vais pas toutes les
reprendre pour pas prolonger trop notre
intervention et il y aura ça figurera
dans notre dans notre document dans
notre trcument écrit mais on on on
s'interroge sur quelques points on sait
que les copies les extraits d'acte de
naissance font nître l'enfant de deux
font nîre don l'enfant de deux parents
de même sexe si demain l'enfant est est
adopté par par deux personnes de même
sexe or jusquà présent notamment en
matière d'adoption pléère on rendait
invisible l'adoption
pléniaire il est clair que là
indirectement l'adoption pléère
deviendra visible on dit pas qu'on peut
l'éviter mais bon on le c'est un constat
deuxièmement euh euh bon ça a déjà été
dit en d'autres circonstances et par
d'autres personnees c'est clair que nous
savons tous dans ce contexte européen
dans lequel n nous situons qu'un certain
nombre de nos pays- voisins admettre la
procréation médicalement assistée euh
bah il faut appeler un chat un chat il
pourra y avoir une PMA qui sera réalisé
à l'étranger il pourra y avoir derrière
euh un l'adoption par l'épouse de la
mère dans cet exemple là rien ne doit
interdire normalement le prononcé
l'adoption en France dès lors que elle
est demandée par la conjointe de la mère
biologique et puis on n' pas interrogé
normalement sur les modalités de
conception de l'enfant donc il faut
admettre qu'on le veuille ou non
indirectement on
validera une PMA qui pourrait avoir été
pratiqué à l'étranger en l'état actuel
de notre législation de manire
de manière frauduleuse alors nous avons
bien compris que dans l'esprit du
législateur il y avait sans doute une
réflexion qui continuerait à être menée
sur ce sujet-là à l'occasion d'un autre
texte mais bon appelons un chat un chat
dès lors que l'on intègre l'adoption on
valide
indirectement la technique même si elle
est pratiquée à l'étranger
donc ces sujets-l seront
certainement intégrés pardon dans une
future réforme de l'adoption ceci dit
plus important pour nous en pratique de
la même manière qu'on a dit tout à
l'heure que cette réforme pouvait être
l'occasion de revaloriser le mariage
civil je crois que tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire qu'il faut absolument
réfléchir à une réforme complète de
l'adoption notre système est
complètement incohérent pourquoi
admettre aujourd'hui qu'un couple par
exemple de partenairire paxé pourra
recourir si ou un couple de concubin
stable à une PMA mais il ne peut pas
adopter un couple de personne de même
sexe marié pour adopter mais peut pas
recourir à une PMA nous avons une
architecture qui se trouve complètement
déséquilibrée là encore nous comprenons
tout à fait que dans le cadre d'un
projet de loi tel que celui-là on ne
puisse pas toucher à tout l'édifice du
mariage mais on voit bien qu'on sort à
chaque fois de la réflexion de mariage
entre personnes de même sexe par rapport
à des mariages de sexe opposés pour dire
qu'on touche à toute l'architecture du
droit de l'adoption et donc là il y a
vraiment
assez rapidement si possible à mener une
réflexion globale sur ce sujet-là euh on
en profite si demain la réflexion a été
menée sur plus globalement toute
l'adoption pour rappeler que il y a des
incohérences dans notre système par
exemple sur le plan fiscal où on traite
différemment la fiscalité entre adopté
et adoptant suivant que j'adopte
l'enfant du conjoint sur adoption
extérieure c'est une adoption simple une
adoption plinière je crois que ça ne se
justifie pas où on met la adoption qui
crée un vrai lien de parenté et il
faudra à un moment donné accepter que
l'on puisse traiter sans doute tout le
monde pareil en tout cas c'est une
réflexion que nous vous faisons il y a
également par rapport au projet de loi
alors peut-être pour nous un petit peu
une interrogation
euh je rappelle que dans l'article 346
actuel du Code civil nul ne peut être
adopté par plusieurs personnes si ce
n'est par deux époux c'est dans
l'adoption pliniiaère et c'est un texte
qui parenvoie s'applique également à
l'adoption alors le projet de loi
revient sur ce principe et il vise trois
hypothèses quel que soit l'Union
contractée là encore c'est pareil on
s'occupe pas de la forme d'union
l'adoption pliniiaire de l'enfant du
conjoint qui est permise lque l'enfant a
fait l'objet d'une adoption pliniiaèire
par le seul conjoint ici on envisage
clairement l'adoption par une personne
seule qui est actuellement permis et
ensuite il pour y avoir l'adoption
pliniiaire par le second conjoint pas de
d'observation particulière sur le plan
juridique là-dessus ensuite il y a
l'adoption simple de l'enfant qui a déjà
fait l'objet d'une adoption pliniiaire
qui sera autorisée si la demande est
formée par le conjoint de l'adoptant et
puis aussi l'adoption simple de l'enfant
qui a déjà fait l'objet d'une adoption
simple autorisée si c'est donc 360
modifié alors là il nous semble que la
coordination de l'alinéa 2 de l'alinéa 3
peut amener peut-être à si on y fait pas
attention à une chaîne d'adoption et à
ça peut nous poser peut-être quelques
quelques difficultés pratiques je vous
donne un un exemple simple madame
Ducroire adopte plinirement une petite
fille qui s'appelle mode et puis elle se
marie quelques années plus tard avec
Monsieur Léon et Monsieur Léon qui est
proche effectivement de mode l'adopte
simplement d'application de 360 alignéa
2 modifié nouvelle rédaction ici
l'autorité parentale sera réalisée par
Monsieur Léon madame Ducroix puis après
il divorce mode à 8 ans l'adoption
simple n'est pas révoquée Monsieur Léon
continue à exercer conjointement
l'autorité parentale puis se remarie
quelques années plus tard avec Madame
lerou et avec 360 alinéa 3 sous réserve
du consentement cro Monsieur Léon madame
lerou peut adopter simplement aussi cet
enfant donc là il faut quand même
réfléchir aux conséquences de ces
solutions là sur le nom de l'enfant sur
l'autorité parentale sur l'obligation
alimentaire sur les droits successoraux
en cas de décès de l'enfant quels seront
les droits successoraux des adoptants
parce que dans notre Code civil 300 168
aliné 1 ne vise pas cette situation on
parle de la famille d'origine et de la
famille donc là aussi c'est pareil ça
peut poser bon je reconnais que les cas
ne seront pas fréquents mais nous disons
simplement que la coordination de l'anné
2 l'ann à 3 peut peut-être poser
quelques questions vous pourrait donner
un deuxième exemple mais je ne voudrais
pas prolonger ça figurera dans notre
dossier 4è 4è sujet conséence sur le
droit au
non alors là aussi quand on touche cette
réforme au T mariage on se rend compte
après le vote en prcture qu'on touche à
à la
totalité de la
législation sur le nom et
donc
ici
notre projet de loi donc dans
l'article 311 21 et le nouvel article 3
son 3 Ligéa 3 euh et bien donc jusqu'à
présent je rappelle dans un groupuel que
en dernier on prenait le nom du père
lorsqu'il y avait un désaccord désormais
ça s'appliquera à tout le monde en cas
de désaccord on euh prendra l'ordre
alphabétique alors on a vu tout
récemment je crois qu'il y a une réponse
mais une question qui a été posée par un
par un
parlementaire bon je suis un peu plus
prudent que lui dans dans dans les
indications parce qu'il nous dit euh que
désormais
donc sauf desésion contraire crit de un
enfant pre le nom de famille des deux
parents on peut supposer que cette
situation prévaudra dans la majorité des
cas en fait on le voit depuis 2002 c'est
pas le casin on se rend compte que les
Français restent très classiques et que
encore le nom unique reste assez
majoritaire même si on voit de temps en
temps le le nom voilà alors simplement
là on prend compte on prend en note que
ça va concerner tout le monde et donc
cette règle de la alphabétique qui
figurait à l'époque dans dans le premier
réforme du n en 2002 qui avait été
abandonné aujourd'hui donc ben on va
traiter tout le monde de la même manière
bon bah il faut intégrer la
conséquence est-ce que c'est nécessaire
ou pas il faut se poser la question on
comprend parfaitement qu'entre deux
personnes de même sexe en cas desaccords
il faudra trancher est-ce que pour les
personnes de même sexe il faut supprimer
la prééminence du nom du mari
question en ce qui concerne non
l'obligation
alimentaire l'obligation alimentaire là
aussi c'est pareil pour cette texte là
comme pour d'autres c'est toujours une
vision général pour nous de tous les
couples nous avons eu dans d'autres
occasions dit queil nous semblait que le
régime de l'obligation alimentaire 204
205 206 du Code civil était obsolète
notamment en ce qui concerne
l'obligation alimentaire qui est dû par
les gens les bellesfilles à leurs
beaux-parents je crois que là aussi dans
le cadre d'un projet de réforme de main
du droit de la famille il faut se saisir
de
notre arsenal juridique en matière de de
d'obligation alimentaire et sans doute
revoir ce fait que la rupture de
l'alliance fait que s'il y a des enfants
issus de l'union je vais devoir donc
devoir encore des aliments à mon
beau-père bmère s'il n'y a pas d'enfant
je veux pas en devoir
je pense que c'est sans doute pas tout à
fait euh cohérent et n'oubliant pas que
l'obligation alimentaire est réciproque
hein c'est surtout ce cette cet aspect
de l'obligation alimentaire qui nous
paraîtrait dev voir faire l'objet d'une
future réflexion là aussi dans le petit
dossier que l'on a préparé on a mis
quelques exemples de situations qui nous
sembleraient ne pas être très cohérente
et puis il faut faut faire attention
aussi avec la multiplication des liens
au risque de multiplication des
obligations alimentaires dans un sens
comme dans l'autre or nous le savons
aujourd'hui sur le terrain l'obligation
alimentaire est un réel problème
euh tout à l'heure je rappelais au
président suur que la première fois où
j'avais rencontré il travaillait sur
tous les tests au moment de la réforme
de la PA de la PSD et cetera nous savons
que au moment de la mise en œuvre par
les départements de ces aides la
situation est aujourd'hui parfois
compliquée pour les famille et nous
voyons aussi sur le terrain de plus en
plus de demandes d'enfants vis-à-vis des
parents ou des grands-parents donc il
faudra peut-être réfléchir à toutes les
conséquences donc sur l'obligation
alimentaire enfin nous souhaiterions
attirer l'attention du Sénat sur les
conséquences en droit international
privé
oui sur le droit international privé on
a deux observations à faire l'une sur le
nouvel article 2021 et l'autre sur le
nouvel article article 167 sur le nouvel
article
2021 c'est une question de terminologie
qui nous qui nous
gêne on dit que dans ce nouvel article
2021 que deux personnes peuvent
contracter mariage lorsque pour au moins
l'une d'elles soit sur lo personnel soit
sa loi de l'État sur le territoire
duquel elle a son domicile ou sa
résidence le permet et donc en ce qui
concerne la reconnaissance en France des
mariages célébrés à l'étranger nous
cette règle de conflit n'a pas de
d'observation particulière sauf pour
nous il nous semble qu'il serait
souhaitable de remplacer à la fois dans
un souci d'intéibilité et
d'accessibilité de la règle de droit la
loocution loi personnelle par loi
nationale et puis c'est surtout les
notions de domicile ou de résidence qui
nous interpelle euh pour rappel si c'est
le domicile qui est pris en compte par
l'officier d'état civil il y a pas de
condition de durée il y a pas de
conditions d'habitation effective qui
n'est exigé par notre instruction
générale relative à l'état état civil et
si c'est le critère de résidence qui est
retenu on nous dit toujours dans ces euh
dans cette instruction que
l'officierétat civil est invité à
adopter une attitude libérale pour la
détermination du domicile donc une
résidence secondaire sur le territoire
français pourra suffire à à une
célébration valable du mariage alors
même par exemple que la loi nationale
l'un des futurs conjoints va prohiber
d'une telle union euh exemple deux
Suisses de même sexe se marient en
France parce qu'ils ont résidence
secondaire en France ils auront deux
statuts juridiques mariés lorsqu'ils
seront en France et euh donc ils ne le
seront plus euh en Suisse où là leur
mariage sera requalifié en partenariat
mais pour la terminologie il nous semble
que donc euh euh l'article 202 aliné 1
devrait plutôt prévoir deux critères de
rattachement alternatif l'un personnel
par la nationalité qui est le critère
classique en la matière et l'autre par
la résidence habituelle c'est-à-dire un
rattachement effectif à la France qui
garantit une stabilité la résidence
habituelle c'est quelque chose qu'on
connaît en droit international privé
pour le statut personnel ça reflète le
milieu effectif de vie de l'intéressé ça
garantit la stabilité il y a beaucoup de
testes qui font référence prenez 31115
par exemple du Code civil en matière de
possession d'état dans la de récent
règlement du 4 juillet 2012 sur les
successions le règlement européen on se
réfère à la résidence habituelle en ces
termes lien étroit et stable avec l'État
concerné et puis on regarde un peu ce
qui se passe chez nos voisins par
exemple en Belgique pour le mariage
entre personne de même sexe c'est un
rattachement territorial par la
résidence habituelle de l'un des
inéressés qui justifie l'éviction d'une
loi personnelle prohibitive au titre de
l'exception de l'ordre publique donc il
ne s'agit pas de euh remettre en cause
la règle elle nous paraît la règle bonne
c'est peut-être une question de
terminologie sur lequel il faudra
réfléchir là aussi on vous met quelques
notes notre deuxème remarque est ensuite
sur le nouvel article 167 du Code civil
qui lui prévoit que en lorsque en vertu
d'une convention consulaire ou à défaut
de la loi de l'État de la résidence
intéressé nos autorités diplomatiques au
consulair ne pourront pas procéder à la
célébration du mariage de de personnes
de même sexe dans l'une au moins une
nationalité française on prévoit donc
que ça pourrait être l'officitat civile
de la commune de de la dernière
résidance enfin un certain nombre
d'hypothèses ici ce texte a pour effet
d'écarter l'application d'une éventuelle
convention consulaire ou de la loi du
lieu de résidence en permettant donc de
délocaliser temporairement la situation
même lorsque l'un des ou l'autre des
époux a conservé des liens avec la
France donc la possibilité qui est
offerte par la loi française peut être
une source potentielle de de danger pour
les pour les conjoints concer con n
prenons l'exemple de deux personnes qui
résideraient en
Russie avec laquelle donc la France a
quand même des liens
privilégié encore en Russie aujourd'hui
on réprime pénalement le mariage entre
personnes de même sexe si demain une
autorité ruses découvre l'existence du
mariage après le retour des intéressés
sur le territoire est-ce que demain ça
ne peut pas poser problème on pourrait
donner aussi d'exemples de pays qui
interdisent si on reste donc dans des
pays membres de l'Union euh donc il y en
a qui ne reconnaissent ni le mariage
enregistré ni le partenari enregistré
pardon ni le mariage entre personnes de
même sexe parfois sont encore hostiles à
l'institution il nous semble aut cas que
l'article 167 s'abstrait d'un principe
fondamental en droit interational privé
de coordination des systèmes juridiques
et
donc il nous semble qu'on est en
contradiction dans ses effets avec
d'autres dispositions protectrices du
couple qui sont issues du projet de loi
vous avvez un article 16 vis par exemple
qui protège les salariés qui ont refusé
une mutation géographique dans un état
qui incrimine
l'homosexualité donc il nous semble que
peut-être une réflexion un peu plus
poussée sur ce nouvel article 167 et ses
conséquences pourrai être mené à
l'occasion de vos débats qui seront très
certainement très riches voilà quelques
brèves réflexions j'ai un petit peu
résumer peut-être en ayant malgré tout
été trop long quelques-unes de nos
remarques voilà monsieur le Président
merci beaucoup Messieurs les Présidents
monsieur le Président du Conseil
supérieur et monsieur le Président de la
section famille je crois que nous avons
tous
été très intéressés par vos exposés qui
sont extrêmement rigoureux et qui posent
de
manière très
précise des questions dont certaines
restent vraiment sans réponse donc pour
les législateurs que nous sommes c'est
infiniment précieux donc j'ai déjà
monsieur revet est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
collègues qui souhaitent
intervenir madame taska mais bien
sûr bon alors la parole je vais la
donner d'abord à nos rapporteurs
Monsieur Michel merci je voudrais
remercier entendu le conse notamment
maître combré que déjà nous avait
apporté des lumières au moment du vote
du Pax dans une ambiance un peu plus
survoltée c'est vrai même si euh car
c'était finalement la première fois que
le Parlement et
l'assemblée établissait une union en
dehors du mariage et donc c'était un peu
plus hard en plus il y avait entre les
auteurs du projet les notaires une
petite difficulté sur est-ce que ça doit
être seulement un contrat notarié ou pas
enfin bon voilà aujourd'hui nous sommes
plus dans les mêmes dispositions et donc
remercie beaucoup mîre combré des de ce
qu'il nous a dit alors je veux peut-être
pas poser des questions mais le rassurer
sur certains points et lui dire ce que
nous comptons faire et puis vous on aura
la note qui nous permettra de
euh c'est vrai que ça je suis satisfait
que les notaires le soulignent que le
mariage ouvert au coupes de même sexe
revalorise le mariage civil voilà à un
moment où il en a bien besoin et donc
grâce aux homosexuels le mariage civil
va être valorisé c'est excellent
monsieur revet mon cher collègue euh sur
la terminologie alors oui nous
regarderons l'article afin d'exclure
expressément ce qui concerne la PMA qui
pour l'instant n'est pas légalisé donc
là-dessus on prend note de ce que vous
dites sur le 3è point alors sur le
troisè point c'est un peu plus compliqué
euh nous avons entendu hier avant-hier
avant-hier je sais plus les les
ministres madame tobira et Madame
mertinotti AV avanier avanier et nous
leur avons ont dit qu'il fallait à tout
prix faire une réforme totale de
l'adoption bon ça c'est dans l'esprit de
tout le monde et que même j'ajoute ça
aurait été de la part du gouvernement
peut-être encore mieux de faire cette
forme d'adoption avant l'ouverture du
mariage comme ça au moins mais bon mais
oui donc cette réforme de l'adoption est
en cours et je dois rencontrer Madame
Bertinotti le plus rapidement possible
me dit-elle afin de
mettre
voilà et et et prendre en compte ce que
vous suggériez mître combré c'est que et
ce qu'on nous a dit ce nous ont dit hier
le conseilp de l'adoption que nous ont
dit les associations de par adopt ce que
nous dirons sûrement le comment il
s'appelle le conse d'adoption hier
c'était l'agence bon c'est que
l'adoption plinière aujourd'hui n'est
plus la même qu'il y a 10 ans 20 ans
voilà on adopte plus de de bébés on
adopte beaucoup d'étranger et donc cette
idée qui est encore dans la tête de
certains psychanalyes d'ailleurs que
l'adoption devait faire disparaître
totalement l'histoire
antérieure dans les fait ne n'est plus
ne peut plus exister voilà donc ça déjà
ça doit être revu également et donc il
faut on va tout à l'heure entendre le
Conseil d'accès aux origines là et
là-dessus évalement il y a à mon avis de
gros progrès à faire mais peut-être dans
un autre texte que dans celui-là par
contre nous sommes tout à fait d'accord
et un amendement nous avons préparé un
amendement maître combré
pour faire pour restreindre la
possibilité de quatre filiations
adoptives et même plus parce que pour
bon voilà donc là-dessus on a bon voilà
on va arranger si dire le texte de
l'Assemblée nationale alors sur le
double nom sur le
nom la question est un peu
compliquée j'avoue que si j'avais le
temps j'irais me transporter dans quelqu
maternité oui car ce qu' on me dit est
totalement
contradictoire on me dit que la plupart
des couples quel qu'il soit même mariés
dans l'euphorie de la naissance d'un
enfant mal informé parce que paraî-il
mal informé donne un prénom et jusqu'au
dernier moment on se dispute pour savoir
quel sera le prénom et finalement on dit
à l'infirmière à l'assistance sociale ou
je sais pas à qui voilà elle s'appellera
ben Noémi très bien et puis c'est
terminé et puis avec ça la maternité va
faire la déclaration à l'état civil
offici d'état civil et donc si les gens
sont mariés c'est le nom du père s'ils
sont pas mariés je sais pas on on
bricoolle alors si c'est vrai si c'est
vrai franchement c'est inadmissible bon
il faudrait que dans toutes les
maternités de France et de Navar il y a
des imprimés en Monet du forme un pour
le prénom un pour le nom de famille
qu'on explique qu'il y a quand même des
assistant social dans les maternités
dans les hôpitaux qu'on explique au aux
parents qui viennent ou à la mère seule
qui VI viennent de mettre un enfant au
monde quelles sont les dispositions qui
vont s'appliquer et et de leur et de
leur permettre de faire un choix un
choix or aujourd'hui il semble que c'est
l'absence de choix qui fait que
peut-être on aurait ce double nom voilà
donc là-dessus on va on va y réfléchir
et voir ce qu'on peut faire bon je sais
que mon collègue de l'Assemblée
nationale est très attaché à la solution
qu'il a trouvé on verra mais c'est vrai
que ça pose un vrai problème
euh bon sur l'obligationaire j'en dis
rien alors sur le droit international
privé j'avoue que c'est avec des
pincettes qu'on toucherait à ces
articles nous avons demandé une
consultation qui n'est pas encore arrivé
à des professeurs de droit spécial droit
international privé on me dit à la
Chancellerie que la question a été
longuement étudiée bien le croire
euh voilà donc pour l'instant j'en dis
pas plus
euh mais euh si euh euh les documents
qu'on nous fournit et les renseignements
qu'on nous donne nous y pousseent nous
toucherons avec des pincettes à euh les
articles qui concernent les
droitationale privé voilà pour le reste
on prendra vous donnerz une note donc on
on tiendra le plus grand compte de ce
que vous avez pu nous dire et je vous en
remercie euh très
chaleureusement merci Monsieur Michel
madame Michel Menier rapporteur pour la
Commission des affaires
sociale merci monsieur le Président donc
pour compléter les les questions de du
rapporteur vous avez dit en en
préliminaire que vous aviez déjà en
quelque sorte une pratique puisque non
seulement les couples paxés mais aussi
les couples mariés à l'étranger qui
viennent en
France pour s'installer où ils vivent
donc je voulais peut-être que vous nous
fassiez un retour quels sont les les
sujets qui sont les plus problématiques
qu'on vous pose qui reviennent le plus
souvent parmi ce que vous avez listé
euh ça serait intéressant que vous nous
fassiez un petit retour si vous le
pouviez et puis pour compléter donc sur
les la notion donc importante qui a mis
en évidence ce projet de loi autour de
l'affiliation et l'adoption je voulais
savoir comment déjà il est possible que
les choses se règlent parce que les
enfants existent il y a déjà des enfants
qui vivent dans des couples personnes de
même sexe qui sont en situation
d'insécurité J
donc voilà qu'est-ce qui est entre le
pire et le moins mal
aujourd'hui merci Madame Meier nous
allons prendre les autres intervenants
sous la présidence de Jean-Pierre Michel
merci donc monsieur rev madame tas on
demandé la parole est-ce qu'il y en a
d'autres car après on
arrêtera
sol voilà donc comme il est voilà 10
minutes pour répondre globalement alors
Monsieur revet oui merci monsieur le
Président merci monieurs les présidents
tarad et combré de la présentation qui
nous a été faite monsieur président
Tarade vous avez commencé votre propos
et à chacune de ces interventions le
président Comé l'a repris en disant il y
a une nécessité de bien faire
réfléchir si la loi est votée aux
conséquences d'application de de cette
loi alors je suppose que vous
faisiez
référence au futur marié entre
parenthèses pour dire avant que vous
mariez on a besoin vous avez besoin de
bien réfléchir des conséquences alors
que le mariage est élargi jeurais tenté
de nous l'appliquer à nous d'abord en
tant que lateur il y a des grands
spécialistes mais mais chacun a une voix
et doit je pense pouvoir voter en
conscience des conséquences du texte ce
qu'il vote c'est d'abord pour nous et je
suis pas sûr qu'on mesure aujourd'hui
toutes les conséquences de l'application
du texte enfin en tout cas moi je mesure
pas parce que et je seraai tenté de dire
monsieur le rapporteur que ce serait
bien qu'on ait un tableau
comparatif des situations si on avait ça
ça éclairerait beaucoup de nos nos
collègues je sais pas si c'est possible
ma question monsieur le Président
lorsque Monsieur le Président de la
République euh dans la campagne
électorale puisque c'est une application
d'une promesse électorale c'est présenté
euh ça nous est présenté comme ça à
lancer cette idée je suis pas sûr et sa
pas lui faire un jure ni à lui ni à ses
conseillers qu'il est prévu toutes les
conséquence de la proposition qu'il
faisait et donc à partir de là et des
statistiques que vous nous avez
donné c'est important vous avez dit euh
il y a de je j'arrondis hein 250000
mariages
209000 Pax et 9000 Pax pour des
personnes de même sexe c'est ce que vous
nous avez indiqué ça veut dire que il y
a pratiquement presque autant de Pax que
de mariage
aujourd'hui et donc l'interrogation est
dès lors que 90 % des
paxes sont des mariages htérosexuel
c'est bien ça si j'ai bien retenu les
chiffres il seraitté intéressant de
savoir pour pour quelle
raison des gens se paxent quittent à se
marier après je peux vous raconter je
vais pas le
allonger une une anecdote une jeune
fille qui vient me voir pour un problème
de déplacement ou autre et et je je lui
demande dans quelle situation parce que
pour essayer d'intervenir il faut avoir
les éléments je lui dis vous êtes marié
non non bon et puis je dit mais attendez
pour essayer de vous rapprocher faut au
moins qu'il y ait quelques éléments elle
me dit je suis je suis paxé je dis
quelle différence vous faites entre le
mariage et le paxe dit mais ça n'a rien
à voir le mariage c'est quelque chose de
sérieux qui engage et autres le PX c'est
une un non mais excusez-moi c'est sa
réponse formulaire administratif après
je verrai si je me marie bien moi je
serais intéressé à savoir pour vous qui
êtes je parle pas de l'affiliation j'ai
compris monsieur le monsieur le
rapporteur que on dissociait les
problèmes de filiation d'adoption à plus
for raison de
procréation de GMA enfin de tout les
tout ce qui nous fait fait problème
aujourd'hui et nous
interpelle du texte lui-même pour
l'instant j'ai même entendu je me suis
dit tiens est-ce que vous allez proposer
le le report de examen que il serait
préférable de légiférer sur l'adoption
avant même de légiférer sur ce texte là
c'est ce que j'ai compris hein il aurait
été non mais peut-être que vous pouvez
en conclure peut-être que que vous allez
en conclure comme ça dans dans les
propositions que vous allez faire euh
est-ce que l'on pourrait avoir une
indication parce que je crois
honnêtement que lorsque le président de
la République a fait la proposition et
il voulait prendre en compte la
situation de personnes de même sexe
puisque le mariage il existait bon et à
partir de là qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
qu'il y a des dispositions qui n'ont pas
été prévues dans le PACT et je crois
qu'on a reçu tous
des personnes qui vivent ensemble et qui
sont de même sexe qui ne sont pas dans
le mariage et qui plutôt qui sont pas
dans le PACT et et dont il serait
ncessaire qu'el y soit pour répondre
vraiment aux attentes de ces personnes
pour lequel le texte de loi est prévu
est-ce que on pourra avoir des éléments
en quoi un aménagement du paxe pourrait
effectivement répondre aux attentes
légitimes
parce que la vie commune de personnes du
même sexe c'est pas un fait nouveau ça
existe depuis tous les temps et que le
législateur s'en préoccupe ça me paraît
légitime c'est pas forcément le mariage
selon moi mais ça sera intéressant
d'avoir ces aspect pour vous qui êtes
notaire et donc tout aspect succession
c'est aspect financier c'est aspect aide
alimentaire et autres avoir tous ces
éléments légitime pour moi en tout cas
de la part de gens qui souhaitent vivre
ensemble merci mon cher collègue madame
taska auparavant je vous indique
monsieur revet que vous suivez à peu
près plus de 50 % des auditions donc
vous êtes très informé de tout ce qui se
dit ici et dans le rapport il y aura des
éléments de comparaison bien entendu
oui merci monsieur le Président moi je
c'est moins une question qu'une d'abord
une une remarque d'ordre d'ordre général
je vous remercie beaucoup de ce que vous
nous avez avait apporté en pointant de
façon très objective les questions
juridiques que soulève ce texte et en
faisant d'ailleurs un certain nombre de
suggestions dont nous ferons le le le
meilleur usage mais ce qui m'importe
dans dans la manière dont vous avez
traité le sujet c'est que vous avez
beaucoup insisté sur le fait que ce
texte doit être considéré comme
affectant l'ensemble des couples quel
que soit je dirais leur leur orientation
sexuel leur composition et tout et euh
je me faisais la réflexion en vous
entendant que nous sommes avec un un
texte de loi qui a été pensé à
l'origine pour répondre pour réparer une
discrimination c'est ça qui était
l'objectif majeur et répondre à des
revendications légitimes d'une minorité
qui est la minorité homosexuelle et on
voit que en en traitant euh ce sujet euh
à à l'attention d'une
minorité en fait on ne peut pas ne pas
toucher à l'édifice complet et c'est ce
que ce qui m'a paru très très
intéressant dans la manière dont vous
avez traiter le le sujet alors bon le
choix politique fait que ce texte passe
avant les révisions générales mais je
pense que dans le débat même sur ce
texte nous nous aurons à prendre en
compte cet effet
global sur la vie des des couples et
puis j'avais une toute petite question
parmi les les paxés combien sont-ils à
venir vous voir dans vos études
notariales pour établir un
contrat Mohamed swali solali c'est c'est
un autre oui c'est l'autre oui merci
monsieur le Président euh je souhaite
revenir sur le constat que vous avez
fait tout à l'heure
euh par rapport à la période de
désaffection euh de mariage que nous
sommes en train de de traverser et euh
vous avez dit que c'est à ce moment là
que euh cette réforme euh qui qui veut
ouvrir le mariage à la catégorie des des
homosexuels euh intervient euh et vous
vous avez vous avez dit que il y aurait
certainement une nécessité de réformer
euh plus en avant l'institution du du
mariage pour revaloriser cette
institution alors j'avais deux questions
mais Jean-Pierre Michel a répondu à la
première euh puisque la première
question consistait à vous demander si
justement cette réforme ne contribue pas
à revaloriser le mariage mais il a dit
que que oui et puis la la la deuxème
question question est-ce que vous avez
d'ors et déjà des idées des pistes de
réflexion euh qui iraient vers la la
revalorisation du
mariage merci bon alors je vais demander
à nos interlocuteurs de bien vouloir
répondre à tout le monde il y a pas eu
que des questions mais bon ceci dit nous
prend vous aurez des documents comme
d'habitude donc voilà noustiendrons le
plus grand compte et vous pouvez euh
répond
merci monsieur le Président oui pour
répondre effectivement à Madame meunier
sur les les problèmes pratiques nous ne
rencontrons pas spécialement de
problèmes pratiques simplement lorsque
nous avons deux personnes de même sexe
qui sont marié et bien euh de personnes
qui achètent un bien immobilier bien
dans notre acte c'est Monsieur épou de
monsieur qui achète un bien immobilier
et voilà avec dans les proportions qui
sont celles qu'ils choisissent ils sont
soumis à un régime de séparation de BI
moitié moitié S sont régime marié s un
régime de communauté là c'est pour le
coup leur leur statut personnel qui
s'applique et on applique le statut
personnel lorsqu'il s'agit de succession
et bien également nous reconnaissons le
le le droit international privé français
reconnaît les situations acquises à
l'étranger donc on traite une succession
en France comme de de personnes du même
sexe comme une succession française euh
effectivement
euh monsieur revet ce texte vous l'avez
igné vous l'avez tout souligné nous
avons essayé de l'étudier sur un plan
extrêmement technique extrêmement
juridique je ne peux pas promettre que
nous avons analyser toutes les
conséquences parce qu'effectivement
aujourd'hui il y a un certain nombre de
situations et c'était dans mon propos
liminaire qui ne sont pas couvertes que
nous n'avons peut-être pas encore toutes
décelé et c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous souhaitons effectivement qu'il y
ait inflexion pour pouvoir anticiper
toute toutes ces situations je m'étais
permis de dire à à Madame tobira que on
touchait là à un pilier du Code civil le
mariage l'institution du mariage est qu
même un un pilier de notre droit et je
vais 10 je vais employer cette formule
faites-nous une belle loi si vous devez
faire une loi parce que le mariage c'est
quand même quelque chose d'important
dans notre texte alors il nous manque un
portalice mesdames messieurs à vous la
plume euh en ce qui concerne
l'information nous nous apercevons etj
combr l'a dit à plusieurs reprises et là
ça concerne tous les couples que
beaucoup de couples ne sont pas informés
des conséquence du mariage ou du non
mariage du paxe ou du non paxe ou
mélange tout donc vous avez
effectivement évoqué un formulaire vous
avez évoqué un de choses comme ça on
s'aperçoit à l'analyse de ces de ces
projets que beaucoup de nos concitoyens
ne sont pas suffisamment informés tout
simplement de la loi et c'est une
réflexion supplémentaire par exemple là
encore c'est quelque chose que nous
avons nous n'avons pas évoqué ici mais
qui devra être pris en compte dans cette
fameuse loi famille qu'on nous annonce
pour bientôt qui est le statut du beau
parents dans les familles recomposé et a
encore famille
recomposé avec des parents de même sexe
ou avec des parents de sexe différents
aujourd'hui dans notre pratique on
rencontre de plus en plus de situations
dans lesquelles et bien nous avons des
enfants qui vivent avec des personnes
qui ne sont pas leurs
parents voilà voilà ce que je voulais
dire en préliminaire et donc maître
combré va répondre peut-être plus
techniquement oui encore que ça reste
aussi très général par rapport à vos
très intéressante question sur sur le pa
alors la rédaction du Pax par les
notaires avait posé problème monsieur le
sénateur Michel la rappelé tout à
l'heure et effectivement c'est pas le
texte de loi d'ailleurs en 1999 c'est
plutôt les les circulaires
administratifes derrière qui ont qui ont
perturbé le jeu c'était pas le
législateur et c'est souvent le cas
malheureusement vous n'êtes pas toujours
servi derrière comme vous pourriez
lesescomter et nous avec par certains
textes d'application ça a été réglé
on se rend compte si vous voulez qu'on a
une montée en puissance alors on n' pas
je crois encore les statistiques sur une
année entière en tout cas moi je ne les
ai pas mais on commence à en faire
régulièrement alors pour des petites
questions Prati alors il y a un
inconvénient alors j'ai 2 secondes la
tribune ce qui est quand même curieux
c'est que si je vais au GREF c'est
gratuit si je vais chez moi qu'on paye
4re honorair bon ben c'est 100 100 190 €
je crois donc c'est pas à mon coûte mais
par contre on perçoit un droit
d'enregistrement pour l'État voilà
l'État perçoit une taxe ça part idiot
mais ça majore de plus de 150 € passer
partout les les frais on peut se dire
est-ce que c'est utile ou pas ça c'est
une parenthèse refermée l'utilité si
vous voulez qui qui qui qui qui qui
paraît intéresser les clients c'est que
s'ils veulent aller faire un Pax
rapidement il y a beaucoup de greffes où
il y a un délai d'attente vous voulez le
conclure aujourd'hui si je peux vous
recevoir demain vous le signez demain et
à l'instant même où vous l'avez fait
chez moi c'est moi qui vais m'occuper de
toutes les formalités vous n'avez rien à
faire donc ça ça correspond à à un
besoin ben ma fois les clients ont le
choix ils viennent ils viennent pas chez
nous ils sont pas obligés de venir mais
visiblement on on on sent qu'on a une
montée en puissance des Pax voilà ce qui
explique d'ailleurs je crois qu'il y a
un chiffre et puis il y a tout notre
conseil que nous donnons je crois que le
président l'a rappelé il y a aussi si
vous voulez avec le recul nous avions
essayé à l'époque de dire qu'aujourd'hui
ce Pax aujourd'hui il a des effets
juridiques importants il marche bien je
répondrai à Monsieur revet dans un
instant là-dessus il marche bien
simplement justement parce qu' est
important le contenu du contrat est
important
des conventions que l'on peut y mettre
et le fait quand on a un document sous
signature privée et et que le greffier a
tamponné on l'a rendu supposez que ce
soit des deux partenaires qui prennent
les deux exemplaires et puis qui les
fassent disparaître ou bien il y en a
qui trafique il peut y avoir c'est sûr
que l'original que je détiens comme tous
les actes authentiques j'en assure la
sécurité j'en assure la garde j'en
assure la diffusion on a perdu des
copies je peux redonner des copies
authentiques ça offre aussi certains
avantages c'est vrai que on n par envie
de de faire de la publicité pour nous
c'est pas l'objet du débat mais c'est
vrai que l'acte authentique de ce
côté-là cont tenu de l'effet juridique
du PCT c'est intéressant alors monsieur
le sénateur c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui il
y a deux analyses possibles des débats
les ont eu et notamment les associations
familiales ont proposé l'idée de
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n pas fait un
espèce de partenariat enregistré comme
l' le problème à mon avis quand même
pour le législateur c'est ou bien on
reviendrait en arrière sur le Pax
j'imagine pas qu'on a un Pax à effet à
géométrie variè suivant que ça serait un
Pax entre personnes de même sexe ou des
personnes de sexe opposé si je dois
mettre dans le Pax les mêmes avantages
que dans le mariage il a une institution
de trop d'un autre côté le Pax
manifestement les les chiffres le disent
montrent il a trouvé aussi sa place dans
la dans dans les choix de nos de nos
citoyens et c'est pas systématiquement
la liberté c'est pas non c'est c'est
comme ça c'est souvent étable d'ailleurs
je crois dans les statistiques il y a un
nombre important de PES qui se
convertissent ensuite en mariage il y a
une espèce d'évolution de de de de la
société qui qui bah qui a le choix qui
donc c'est vrai que il y a une
alternative qui était tout à fait
possible qui de dire on réserve le
mariage aux personnes de sexe opposé et
on crée un contrat à part pour les
personnes de même sexe mais à ce
moment-là soit on fait quatre types de
contrat hein le mariage le Pax un
partenariat enregistré il y a le
concubinage qui est quand même
aujourd'hui quelque chose de reconnu il
faut reconnaître que c'est compliqué moi
nous on a notre rôle à nous notaire ce
n'est pas de porter des appréciation
là-dessus je crois que vous êtes des
élus de la nation c'est vous qui avez la
responsabilité de la loi nous sommes
dans une démocratie il y a une majorité
qui décide ben nous exécuterons donc
nous on n' pas d'appréciation à à à ce
niveau-là en revanche vous avez tous
compris notre message autour du mariage
et je vous remercie monsieur le sénateur
en 1999 j'étais le rapporteur de notre
congrès sur le droit de la famille c'est
au moment où nous avions beaucoup
travailler avec Monsieur Michel et
j'avais dit deadam Guigou dans mon
discours c'est quand même curieux qu'en
France euh il est plus facile de se
marier ou de faire un enfant et de le
que de passer le permis de conduire
regarder toutes les épreuves que nous
subissons mais même le permis de chasse
un simple permis de chasse il vous faut
des épreuves et cetera il y a aucune
donc il y a aucune information préalable
réel alors des mairies ont fait des
efforts ces dernières années Tex évolué
mais c'est vrai que ce que vous avez
signalé monsieur le sénateur dans les
maternités me paraît sur le terrain
exact nos citoyens n'ont pas
suffisamment d'information et
on avait à l'époque en 1999 voté une
proposition qui pouvait paraître un
petit peu éconoclaste mais enfin qui
était la suivante on devait on avait
supprimé le service militaire
obligatoire on avait fait la journée de
préparation de l'appel à la défense et
on se disait mais bon faire la formation
d'instruction civile sur des sujets
comme celle-là sur des collégiens ou des
lycéens ils ont peut-être pas la
majorité requise ensuite après on
s'éparpille il y a effectivement une
période de la vie là où on est tous
majeurs où on peut réunir toutes les
classes d'âge bah est-ce que
soit on pourrait réorienter cette
journée soit on pourrait l'élargir et il
serait intéressant qu'il y ait un jour
que toutes les classes d'âge les
instruits et les pas instruits ceux qui
savent lire et ceux quient lire puissent
avoir une véritable information avec des
modes de communication comme ils sont
permis aujourd'hui aussi bien sur les
modes de conjugalité que sur les modes
de de création de liens de filiation que
sur les conséquences parce que c'est
clair vous l'avez compris et c'est notre
message de praticien sur le terrain les
gens mélangent tout parce que dans la VI
tous les jours on mélange tout ce qui
est parfaitement compréhensible et là je
crois qu'on a vraiment un effort tous
ensemble à à faire sur sur sur la
revalorisation du mariage voilà je sais
pas si on a à peu près répondu à vos
questions et bien il me reste à vous
remercier monsieur le Président maître
madame pour comment j'allais dire votre
objectivité pour les éléments que vous
avez donné pour améliorer le texte qu'on
par pas à portalisme enfin on va essayer
de de l'écrire peut-être de façon pour
certain articles plus plus lisibles
c'est une exigence du Conseil
constitutionnel lisibilité de la loi en
tout cas et grâce àos vos conseils je
pense que Monsieur revet sera
partiellement satisfait même s'il est
globalement satisfait voilà
merci mes chers collègues nous allons
poursuivre après les notaires les
avocats et à la fin les magistrats voilà
et puis entre deux les
origines
donc nous avons fait appel au nationale
du
barreau qui réunit l'ensemble des des
avocats même si il y a encore des
association particulière pour les
bâtonniers de Paris le bâtonnier de
province et cetera et cetera mais bon
voilà donc
euh il y a des des difficultés des
excuses des retards peu
importe nous avons ici madame Corine
denoî binteux qui est avocate membre du
conseil de l'ordre de Paris qui je suis
suppose PL beaucoup dans les affaires
familiales et qui va nous donner la
position du conse notariat si Madame
poiv Leclair arrive la parole après pour
répondrex questions qui ser
éventuellement posé quand à Madame
aboudar elle s'excuse n' pas pu nous
rejoindre même si Sophie venait pour la
voir
Provence parce que madame sophiein est
présente ça je dis pour
l'extérieur voilà donc maître vous
pouvez je sais pas un quart d'heure 20
minutes nous avons 1 heure en tout on
veut pas trop dépasser parce que jusqu'à
m de 1h3 ça dure ce matin voilà donc et
puis après on posra des questions merci
en tout cas merci monsieur le rapporteur
j'ai peut-être effectivement faire un un
point suffisamment court pour permettre
davantage de questions parce qu'en fait
je je me suis permis de venir assister à
diverses auditions que vous avez réalisé
la semaine dernière et cette semaine et
donc j'ai pu cibler un peu les
préoccupations que vous aviez
euh par ailleurs j'ai déjà rencontré
certaines certains d'entre vous puisque
je me suis déjà présenté devant vous il
y a quelques mois et euh en substance
aujourd'hui mon discours va être
sensiblement le même et a pour objet de
vous dire que le texte qui est présenté
touche à des problématiques essentielles
qui doivent être analysés en profondeur
avec la plus grande prudence il ouvre le
mariage au couple de même sexe en ayant
pour objectif un terme de mettre un
terme aux différences existantes sur le
plan juridique avec les les couples
hétérosexuels donc comme je vous le
disais j'ai assisté à quelques auditions
devant votre assemblée la semaine
dernière et j'ai entendu finalement que
vos interrogations portaient assez peu
sur la question du
mariage le droit au mariage entraîne un
droit au divorce et en cela évidemment
l'ouverture du mariage au couple de même
sexe est évidemment une avancée une
avancée juridique en terme de protection
donc je voudrais me concentrer si vous
voulez vouz bien sur la problématique de
l'adoption parce qu'elle doit
s'accompagner d'une réflexion plus vaste
sur une refonte totale de nos textes sur
l'affiliation Madame le Ministre de la
Famille a été interrogé par un membre de
votre assemblée il y a quelques jours
sur le calendrier envisagé pour réformer
l'affiliation je crois qu'elle n'a pas
apporté de réponse précise sur ce
calendrier et il semble que que cela
n'interviendrait pas avant le printemps
comme cela a été initialement envis
et c'est évidemment pour nous praticiens
de droit de la famille ce qui est la
préoccupation
essentielle comme vous l'avez vu donc
j'ai j'ai assisté également aux
auditions des professeurs de droit la
semaine dernière et c'est intéressant
parce que quel que soit finalement les
prises de position individuelles qui
sont qu'on comprend
admimot on voit que les juristes et les
praticiens du droit parlent tous de la
nécessité d'une réforme générale
complète de l'affiliation il vous parle
de la né nité d'examiner les textes sur
l'affiliation dans leur ensemble et pas
seulement sur la base de ce seul projet
puisque c'est finalement les
interrogations annexes qui sont qui sont
les plus fondamentales
ici c'est un texte qui se veut
protecteur des statuts de l'enfant de sa
place dans la société civile et c'est
difficilement contestable sur ce point
dans son principe mais on doit veiller à
une cohérence des textes et au fait que
la protection que l'on souhaite
apporter sera donc
réel
euh l'enfant ne choisit ni la famille
dans laquelle il grandit ni la
séparation de ses parents dans les
procédures de séparation les magistras
en pratique s'intéresse pour statuer sur
la résidence de l'enfant aux habitudes
et aux repères que sont l'école les amis
la famille et le couple parental au
premier chef le fait qu'en cas de
séparation il n'y ait pas de lien
juridique entre l'enfant et celui ou
celle qu' a élevé comme le sien même
s'il est même s'il ne l'est
juridiquement pas et est une réelle
difficulté pour nous parce que nous
n'avons pas les moyens de garantir le
maintien du lien de de ce parent à
l'enfant toute mesure donc qui permet
notamment dans cette hypothèse la
garantie du maintien du lien est
évidemment intéressante pour nous en
pratique mais mon propos encore une fois
se veut incitatif à la plus grande
prudence dans la mesure où compenu des
enjeux il est indispensable de prendre
le temps de la réflexion indispensable
que cette réforme ne soit pas précipitée
qu'elle touche à toutes les questions
qui doivent se poser et qu'elle
n'entraînne pas des conséquences qui
n'auraient pas été préalablement
examiné puisqu'il s'agit d'avancer sur
la reconnaissance en terme juridiques
des familles homoparentales qui existent
au demeurant déjà la question serait de
savoir s'il ne serait pas l'occasion de
se demander ce qu'est la famille
d'aujourd'hui et ce que ce qu'on veut
qu'elle soit demain ne serait-il pas
l'occasion de se dire que les textes
relatif à laaffiliation doivent en tout
état de cause être réformé sans plus
attendre parce qu'ils ne correspondent
plus à la réalité des familles
d'aujourd'hui que les couples soient
hétérosexuels ou homosexuels ils ne
correspondent plus à la réalité de la
vie des gens que nous recevons dans nos
cabinets que nous ayons à assister des
adultes ou que nous soyons avocats
d'enfants la refondte des textes est
nécessaire mais la réflexion doit être
évidemment plus vaste et concerné non
pas seulement l'adoption sur la base de
texte qui vous est proposé mais la PMA
l'agpa l' l'accès aux origines et la
présomption de paternité peut-être
s'agissant de l'adoption cette question
doit être examinée à l'ONE de
différentes problématiques parlons
d'abord donc du Code civil qui on
détermine les conditions pour mémoire
l'adoption qu'elle soit plinière ou
simple est aujourd'hui seulement ouverte
au couplees marié depuis plus de 2 ans
ainsi qu'à toute personne célibataire
âgé de depuis de plus de 28 ans
l'adoption conjointe n'est ouverte au
concubin n n'est pas ouverte au
concubins ou au partenaires liés par
unax au regard du texte texte qui permet
le mariage pour tous les couples qu'ils
soit hétérosexuel ou homosexuel on peut
légitimement s'interroger sur le sens du
maintien d'une telle catégorisation des
couples accessibles à
l'adoption quel en serait le sens si les
couples homosexuels se trouvent
contraints de se marier pour fonder une
famille via
l'adoption c'était les propos tenus par
Martine gros qui a été sociologue qui a
été entendu dans le cadre du projet de
loi et qui disait aujourd'hui un enfant
surdonné hors mariage seuls les couples
sexuel devrait donc se marier pour être
parents ensemble ce qui crée donc une
incohérence vous le comprendrez bien
parlons aussi des conditions dans
lesquelles les adoptions interviennent
en
pratique j'ai assisté aux auditions des
représentants d'association la semaine
dernière qui était tout à fait
intéressante et on comprend qu'il
n'existe pas
apparemment de politique commune du
territoire en matière d'adoption chaque
conseil général et maître de son dép
artement en la matière à tel point
qu'admimot certaines associations
expliquent qu'il existe aujourd'hui une
sorte de forum shopping de l'adoption
que certains candidats choisissent de
s'installer dans tel ou tel département
dans l'espoir d'accéder enfin au statut
de parents à défaut d'harmonisation des
pratiques sur le plan national on peut
donc s'interroger sur l'avenir d'une
adoption qui serait ouverte au coupes de
même sexe comment s'assurer qu'au niveau
national aucune discrimination donc si
le texte aboutit n'existera entre les
dossiers des couples hétérosexuels et
ceux des couples homosexuels ou encore
de célibataires en l'état quelle analyse
pouvons-nous faire nous avocats d'un
droit qui n'entraîne pas des effets
juridiques uniformes sur l'ensemble du
territoire
national parlons des circonstances
maintenant de la naissance de l'enfant
dont on permet l'adoption par le
conjoint première hypothèse il peut
s'agir d'un enfant élevé au sein d'un
couple homosexuel mais né d'une
précédente union hétérosexuelle mais
nous savons que cette situation est tout
à fait fa résiduel deuxème hypothèse il
s'agit d'un enfant né du rapprochement
d'un couple d'homme et d'un couple de
femme c'est-à-dire quatre adultes
parents quatre modes d'éducation
différents une multitude de délégations
d'autorité parental pour gérer le
quotidien h grands-parents susceptibles
d'agir pour obtenir un droit de visite
et d'hébergement et un contentieux
catastrophique en cas de séparation avec
un enfant qui perdra inévitablement les
repères qu' aura sans doute eu déjà
beaucoup de mal à construire
indiscutablement dans cette hypothèse
permettre l'adoption au sein des couples
de même sexe simplifie la situation
c'est
certain troème hypothèse une hypothèse
très courante nous le savons
parfaitement c'est l'enfant qui est né
d'une procréation médicalement assisteré
ou d'une gestation pour
autruit comme vous le savez ces deux
points ne sont pas abordés par le projet
de loi et il me paraît difficile de
tenir un raisonnement juridique cohérent
qui aboutit à conférer le droit
d'adopter l'enfant du conjoint dans un
coup couple de même sexe sans pour
autant se positionner sur les
circonstances de sa
naissance un membre de votre assemblée
interrogait madame le garde des saau sur
le point de savoir si autoriser
l'adoption n'entraînait pas dé facto
celle de l'ouverture très rapide à la à
la PMA et la GPA évidemment cette
question est essentielle alors sur la
GPA madame learde des saau a rappelé que
le gouvernement n'envisageait pas de la
rendre possible il est vrai que face au
risque d'exploitation des plus pauvres
par la marchandisation du corps de la
gestatrice et la conciliation impossible
de la GPA avec les principes juridiques
du droit français choisir d'ouvrir une
telle voie semble difficile cependant il
ne faut pas nier la réalité aujourd'hui
en France de nombreux enfants de couple
homosexuel mais aussi hétérosexuel sont
issu d'une gestation pour autrui et son
malgré son interdiction qui est d'ordre
public jusqu'à présent on ne pouvait pas
faire transcrire sur les registres
d'état civil français des actes p
pourtant valablement passer à l'étranger
les enfants nés dans le casadre d'une
gestation pour autruit ne disposaient
que de leur acte d'état civil étranger
ce qui nous posait bien évidemment le
problème en pratique par la circulaire
du 25 janvier dernier le ministre de la
Justice s'est penché sur la question de
la nationalité de ses enfants et elle
permet de ne pas pénaliser ses enfants
puisque même si la GPA demeure
strictement interdite cette circulaire
d'ne aux enfants qui ont la nationalité
française en raison du lien de filiation
qui les unit à leurs parents la possib
de la voir reconnaître c'est donc une
avancée notable qui s'inscrit dans une
conformité de nos
textes sur la PMA maintenant pour
mémoire elle est ouverte à tout couple
composé d'un homme et d'une femme qu'il
soit marié ou non et désormais son
conditions de vie commune durée de vie
commune il ne faut pas ignorer la
réalité une grande part des enfants de
conjoints qui sont adoptés au sein d'un
couple homosexuel sera issue de la PMA
et ne pas permettre aux femmes de
concevoir cet enfant dans un un cadre
légal reviendrait finalement à
encourager à mon sens le contournement
de la loi
française queles que soient les
positions prises sur ces différents
sujets et sur toutes les réflexions qui
découlent de la question de savoir si
l'on doit ouvrir l'adoption au coupes de
même sexe il faut garder à l'esprit que
l'adoption en tant que filiation choisie
est un acte fort une démarche active et
une prise de
responsabilité dans une évolution des
textes vers une filiation juridique
chisi ne serait-il pas l'occasion de
s'interroger sur le point de savoir si
maintenir encore la révocabilité de
l'adoption simple fait sens
aujourd'hui enfin lorsque les thèmes de
l'adoption ou de la procréation
médicalement assisté sont évoqué il est
une question qu'on doit nécessairement
envisager et c'est celle de l'accès aux
origines les textes internationaux
prévoient un accès aux origines et pour
mémoire la Convention de New York et la
convention internationale relative au au
droit de l'enfant précise que l'enfant a
dans la mesure du possible le droit de
connaître ses parents ça n'est pas un
droit impératif mais c'est une
indication d'une direction dans laquelle
les États signataires doivent doivent
aller ce droit à connaître ses origines
disparaît dans certaines hypothèses du
droit interne et bien évidemment celle
de l'accouchement sous
X sur ce point le droit français
réaffirme son attachement à la vérité
biologique même si quelques évolutions
ont marqué une ouverte
je pense à l'article L 2226 du code de
l'action sociale et des familles qui
utilise la formule l'importance pour
toute famille de connaître de connaître
ses origines et son histoire je pense
aussi à la à la création d'une autorité
indépendante pour recevoir les demandes
d'accès aux origines des enfants n
sousic le Conseil national pour l'accès
aux origines
personnelles dans ce contexte crite de
la revendication des enfants nés dans
une famille homoparentale qu'il soit
issu d'une procréation médicale
éellement assisté ou d'une gestation
pour autruit quit du don anonyme des
gamettes et du risque de chute du nombre
de donneurs quit de la conciliation de
cette recherche avec
l'adoption enfin et pour finir un mot
sur l'action recherche de
paternité pour mémoire l'action
recherche de paternité renvoie à
l'article 327 du Code civil et permet à
un enfant d'établir en justice sa
filiation paternelle cette action
recherche de paternité a-t-elle encore
sa place endroit dans un monde qui
voudrait orienté vers une prime à
l'affiliation affective sur
l'affiliation
biologique lors d'une précédente
audition madame le sénateur TASC
évoquait la question de la recherche de
paternité sur le plan du droit des
femmes ce n'est pas une question qui m'a
été posée à moi mais je me permet de de
d'avoir une réflexion sur ce point parce
que c'est effectivement une question
très intéressante et à mon sens le lien
biologique et les conséquences qu'on
cherche à faire établir en pratique sont
davantage de l'ordre du droit des hommes
que celui du droit des femmes parce que
les contentieux que nous avons dans nos
cabinets sont plus souvent menés par des
hommes qui refusent d'être de simples
géniteurs et qui revendique leur
autorité parentale considérons cependant
par hypothèse que la femme soit en
demande d'établissement de laaffiliation
peut-on encore au terme d'une évolution
de la filiation autoriser une action
recherche de paternité alors même
qu'aucune vie commune n'a été partagée
entre la mère et le géniteur de
l'enfant si l'on raisonne en terme de
droits des femmes il me semble qu' qu'il
réside plus aujourd'hui dans la
possibilité de choisir d'être maire en
ayant la faculté de recourir librement à
la PMA en étant célibataire ou alors
même qu'elle n'a aucun problème de
stérilité mais qu'elle n'entretient pas
de relation
hétérosexuellees en conclusion la plus
grande prudence s'impose l'ouverture du
mariage à tous les couples est une
immense avancée pour notre droit mais la
conciliation des intérêts avec le droit
de laaffiliation n'est pas sans soulever
de véritables questions de fond auxquel
le législateur devra bien évidemment
répondre avec la plus grande
attention le fait d'autoriser l'adoption
ne règle que partiellement les
difficultés en terme de rupture
d'égalité il est donc tout à fait
impossible de faire l'économie d'une
réforme totale des textes de
l'affiliation à très court terme je
partage la position du membre de votre
assemblée qui avait interrogé le
Ministre de la Famille à ce sujet donc
sur le calendrier des événements et je
crois qu'il est souhaitable de fixer une
une échéance pour cette réforme globale
de
l'affiliation merci beaucoup maître
alors
euh on va prendre bon moi je je vous
remercie de votre contribution qui qui
pose toutes les questions que nous nous
posons voilà bon alors c'est vrai que
euh on s'interroge pas beaucoup sur
l'ouverture du mariage au coup des mêmes
sexe parce que c'est une réalité qui a
été votée par l'Assemblée nationale et
que nous voterons euh bon voilà ensuite
dans le texte on prévoit l'adoption par
ces
coupes ces articles concernent en fait
tous les couplle et pas seulement les
couples homosexuels Paron voilà donc
là-dessus nous avons des interrogations
sur la rédaction des articles nous avons
des modifications qui seront faites
notamment sur le sur le nom notamment
sur les doubles ou les cadrupes
filiation adoptive notamment bon pour
essayer de de limiter tous ces cas-là ce
concerne d'ailleurs tous les couples
tous les couples bon ensuite c'est vrai
que dans ce texte là le gouvernement n'a
pas voulu en mettre
plus et que d'après ce qu'a dit Madame
mertinoti l'autre jour il y aurait un
projet de loi dit famille mais qui sera
pas que famille je suppose qui viendrait
à l'automne après consultation du Comité
national d'éthique notamment sur la PMA
bon là-dessus mais c'est pas le débat
aujourd'hui je veux pas le truc moi je
dis à Madame mertinoti qu'il faut très
rapidement faire un projet de loi sur
l'adoption mettre à plat tout car comme
vous l'avez pointé aujourd'hui ça ne
correspond plus à la réalité notamment
on va le voir tout à l'heure avec le
l'AC aux origines on nadopte plus de
bébé donc on ne peut plus dire comme
ditent certains psychanalystes que
l'adoption c'est une nouvelle famille et
qu'on coupe tout le reste que T n'existe
plus c'est faux on a de plus en plus
d'enfants déjà plus grands ou d'enfants
ang qui qui voi bien et qui ne sont pas
issus de ce coupe donc tout ça est à
revoir j'espère que le gouvernement le
fera et que nous serons saisis peut-être
en même temps ou avant d'un projet de
loi sur l'adoption pour le
reste le gouvernement envisage c'est
vrai après
qu'onéthique la PMA il se refuse
envisager totalement la GPA je dis ce
que j'en pensais je dis pas autre chose
aujourd'hui voilà donc toutes ces
interrogations nous les avons bien sûr
pour le reste nous pensons que
l'ouverture du mariage au coup
homosexuel est fait comme l'a dit hier
monsieur Baudis fait mais mais fa un
certain nombre de discrimination ne
serait-ce que des discriminations même
indirectes collatéral voilà et puis
après la réflexion s'imposera donc je
vais demander à Madame Menier si elle a
des questions à vous poser monsieur
revet a demande la parole y y a-t-il
d'autres collègues qui veulent poser des
questions car je fais masse du
tout alors Monsieur rev pour l'instant
mais après faut pas avoir de vous pouvez
plutôt avoir des comment on dit ça vous
pouvez dire non après voilà mais si vous
dites pas oui maintenant vous direz pas
oui après voilà donc est-ce qu'il y a
d'autres personnes qui demandent la
parole voame Catherine
taska monsieur le Président et quand je
la veux je la demande ben oui mais pas
après parce qu'il faudra terminer à
l'heure précise donc vous l'aurez et
puis vous me direz si non non je ne la
demande pas vous la demandez pas
d'accord bon euh Virginie
bon on verra he parce que là ça va bon
alors non mais c'est Madame madame poivé
declire va va commencer par répondre
comme ça ça lui permettra de voilà alors
Michel Meier rapporteur pour av pour la
commission des affaires sociales merci
Madame Denois bante moi j'ai pas
forcément de questions à vous poser
parce que vous avez brossé c'est vrai
l'ensemble des problématiques en en
soulevant
certains sujets donc qui vous paraissent
parfois incohérents et que la loi devra
d'une manière ou d'une manière ou d'une
autre répondre si ce n'est par cette loi
làà en tout cas c'est sur celle à venir
sur l'adoption et les filiation général
non moi je voulais revenir mais sans
mapusantir sur le dernierre aspect de
votre propos c'est-à-dire la recherche
en paternité et c'est vrai que
n'oublions pas 8 % des naissances ce
n'est pas rien 8 % des naissances
aujourd'hui en France se font sans père
entre guillemets enfin déclarer et donc
est-ce du côté des droits des femmes ou
du côté des droits des hommes toujours
est-il que la question peut être discuté
mais j'en conviens pas ici et pas en ce
moment et moi je redis que si on veut
être responsable aussi bien en tant
qu'homme ou en tant que femme sur les
naissances que l'on choisit d'avoir on a
des moyens et peut-être là aussi on peut
développer d'autres pratiques et
politiques publiques en matière de
prévention voilà
oui merci monsieur le rapporteur
président euh maître merci de l'exposé
que vous venez de de nous faire euh on a
compris que ayant été
auditeur la semaine dernière vous avez
accès en fonction de ce que vous
ressentiez des questions qui se posaient
ici et donc que vous avez orienté votre
intervention sur les problèmes
d'adoption de filiation euh bon euh je
crois qu'à
l'unanimité je pense pouvoir le dire
devant monsieur le rapporteur qui l'a
dit nous pensons que ce problème de
l'adoption doit être vu dans sa
globalité monsieur le rapporteur disait
que d'ailleurs il e fallu l'examiner
avant même le texte sur le mariage ce
qui était préférable à plus forte raison
les problèmes de PMA ou GPA qui sont
encore beaucoup plus
complexes moi je monsieur monsieur quand
pour expliquer monsieur rapporteur vous
avez dit bon nous
voterons le texte sur le mariage ou
autre je pense que vous incluiez pas
forcément l'ensemble des membres qui
sont ici parce qu'il peut y avoir je
veux dire le
rapporteur c'est bien comme ça que je
l'ai compris monsieur le rapporteur
alors M moi je reviendrai justement sur
le
mariage parce que tout à l'heure et
juste avant vous nous auditions nous
auditionnons le notariat président du
notariat qui a eu cette phrase en
commençant sur la nécessité de bien
faire réfléchir les conséquences liées à
la notion de mariage s'il est étendu à
tout le monde en disant on n'est pas sûr
et je crois que c'est rarement
d'ailleurs le cas parce que quand les
gens se marient ou autres c'est pas leur
première priorité hein en général c'est
plutôt l'amour qui les qui les réunit et
et donc il pensent pas forcément aux
conséquences de ce qui découleront euh
et
c'est vrai moi je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure pour les comment dirais-je les
jeunes ou moins jeune qui se marie c'est
encore plus vrai pour le législateur qui
lui vote un texte alors qui pour lequel
il devrait analyser pouvoir analyser
avant toutes les conséquences de son
vote ce qu'on fait entre nous assez
rarement sauf des spécialistes hein il y
a pas de problème alors ma question
concerne le le fait du mariage vous êtes
amené sans doute à plaider je suppose
j'interroge les deux deux avocats que
nous avons la chance d'avoir vous êtes
amené à plaidé tout à la fois sans
doute pour des divorces ou autres pour
des mariages htérosexuel aujourd'hui ou
pour des gens qui ont été paxés et qui
souhaitent en
sortir quels sont les points sans sans
révéler de secret si vous voulez qui
ressorte des cons
soit du mariage lui-même soit du Pax et
de ce qui n'a pas été introduit par le
Pax dans le Pax à l'origine
et ce auquel finalement quand on reçoit
les gens allez soyons clair on fait de
la politique mais enfin il y a
l'idéologie d'un côté et puis à la
réalité on sait très bien que les
personnes
homosexuel ce qui compte c'est ces
aspects qui n'ont pas été pris en compte
moi j'ai reçu il y a peu de temps tout à
la fois un gay et une lesbienne qui étit
ensemble depuis 20 ans chacun de leur
côté qui avait enfants
ou procréé en ayant à l'étranger
ou homosexuel qui ont adopté chacun de
leur côté puisqu'ils pouvaient pas bon
et qui nous ont dit mais on voudrait
quand même on vit ensemble on continue
de vivre on a acheté notre maison on a
associ à cela et aujourd'hui on est
traité différemment alors que on a une
vie on considère nous qu'on a une vie
normale et
cette situation elle est pas nouvelle a
existé depuis le temps et donc c'est la
responsabilité du législateur de la
traiter mais vraiment de la traiter en
mesurant toutes les conséquences des
choix que l'on fait alors à travers ce
que vous avez pu plaider est-ce que vous
pouvez donner quelques indications par
rapport à
ça merci Virginie cl vous avez je v dire
à notre collègue Charles rev qui est
très assidu ici qu'il a sûrement entendu
la dernière excuse euh la dernière
remarque de mîre combré donc les
notaires ne sont pas des
révolutionnaires hein je pense pas ce
qu'il pense vraiment pas qui nous a qui
vous a dit oui on pourrait penser à un
autre statut d'union civile pour les
homosexuel mais franchement c'est pas du
tout bon parce que ça en ferait quatre
ou cinq et ça suffit comme ça donc je
pense que vous ça vous incitera
peut-être à voter pour le
mariageir vous ne les avez pas et et
nous ne les avons pas pour 95 % d'entre
nous que dans au Sénat on a des rapports
très cordiaux pour aller de l'avant bah
heureusement VO
est merci monsieur le Président je vous
en prie euh je voudrais revenir sur sur
une phrase que que vous avez prononcé
alors que j'ai peut-être mal comprise ou
qui en tout cas à mon sens pourrait être
explicité un peu mieux vous avez avz dit
que ne pas légaliser en matière de
certaines pratiques de PMA reviendrait
encourager le détournement de de la loi
ça me surprend un petit peu que de dire
ne pas légaliser revient encourager le
détournement enfin
euh est-ce que c'est vraiment ce que
vous vouliez dire ou est-ce que c'est
plutôt ne pas légiférer parce que
particulièrement en pratique de PMA
comme d'adoption d'ailleurs on est
confronté quand même à à des droits ou
des des des intérêts peut-être parfois
un peu un peu contraires ou un peu
contradict
et il me semble que c'est plutôt
l'équilibre entre tous ces droits qu'il
faut arriver à à retrouver le droit de
la femme certes mais le droit de l'homme
donneur aussi un donneur de sperme le
fait en tout cas ce que moi je connais
pour aider une femme stérile ou un
couple stérile à avoir des enfants pas
forcément pour servir de la PMA entre
guillemets de convenance c'est un terme
qui a été souvent utilisé donc si on
devait aller vers là c'est une chose on
est favorable on l' pas c'est pas le
débat aujourd'hui mais en tout état de
cause la moindre des choses serait que
le donneur en soit informé c'est quand
même un donneur d'organes quand on donne
un rein c'est pas pour que quelqu'un qui
est très riche et cetera en est trroit
c'est pour que quelqu'un qui est menacé
de mourir parce qu'il en manque un en
est un donc je je pense que les les
objets et les objectifs de ces dons
certes très particulers que sont les
dons de gamett ce doivent être fait dans
la plus grande transparence on a parlé
de recherche de paternité aussi on a vu
récemment à la à la télévision des
reportages sur des papas qui ont été
spoliés de leur paternité parce que la
maman est partie accoucher toute seule
et cetera et cetera et puis qui se
retrouve tout à coup à fubler entre
guillemets d'un fils d'une fille de 8
ans 10 ans 15 ans 16 ans que sais-je euh
donc là aussi le le droit des papas et
le droit des enfants à connaître leur
papa si le papa est prêt à accepter sa
paternité est important à prendre en
considération donc voilà il me semble
que ce terme de de devoir de légaliser
me paraît un peu surprenant et peut-être
un peu
fort parole d'abord peut-être mîre
Poivet pour répondre voilà et
puis bien sûr la parole nous avons
encore presque une
demi-heure merci
Monsieur pour ce qui me concerne je je
voudrais faire une remarque en ce qui
concerne la la
PMA je crois que nous ne devrions pas
avoir à légiférer la PMA de devrait être
d'entrée de jeu ouverte à tous les
couples mariés car si elle n'est ouverte
qu'au coupllees mariés htér sexuel on va
tomber sous le coup de la CEDH qui va
considérer que nous faisons un statut
différent aux gens mariés selon qu'ils
sont hétérosexuels ou homosexuels la
CEDH dans l'article 8 ni l'article 14 ne
permettent de condamner un état qui
refuserait un mariage ho sexuel en
revanche nous serons condamnés la France
sera condamnée si elle n'aligne pas le
droit de ses couples sans tenir compte
du fait qu'ils sont seulement mariés
hein je me permets d'attirer l'attention
de tout le monde sur un arrêt de la CEDH
qui s'appelle gas et du bois du 15 mars
2012 que j'ai apporté que je vous
laisserai si vous voulez je pense que
c'est une question intéressante ce qui
fait que en réalité l'ouverture de la
PMA elle est une conséquence
nécessaire de du
mariage pour tous voilà ça c'est un
point qui me paraît important deuxième
point pardon veut dire qu' dire que
c'est médical mais oui c'est ça c'est
c'est c'est de toute façon c'est
nécessairement sinon on va avoir un
statut de on va discriminant par rapport
au couples qui
sont homosexuel deuxièmement si la PMA
ne s'accompagne pas
d'une d'une loi sur la GPA on va
assister à ce qui se passe au Canada
c'est-à-dire à une féminisation de la
filiation car il n'y aura pas de
filiation paternelle possible en dehors
d'une hétérosexualité c'est-à-dire un
homme qui arrivera dans un mariage
homosexuel avec pourvu d'enfant d'une
relation antérieure hétérosexuelle mais
si on est dans une relation purement
homosexuel ça veut dire que ces hommes
qui se marient qui vivent ensemble ne
peuvent pas pour le moment avoir
d'enfants et ça veut dire que la seule
filiation qui va exister ça va être une
filiation qui va être essentiellement
féminine le Canada connaî cet
inconvénient puisqu'il n'a pas admis la
GPA pour le moment ce qui fait que
actuellement il y a des des GPA qui se
font aux États-Unis qui ne sont pas loin
il sont à San Francisco ou à Los Angeles
voilà donc ça ce
sont de deux axes sur la la PMA et la
GPA qui me paraissent important euh je
voudrais parler de l'intérêt de
l'enfant parce que je pense que cet
enfant qui est l'objet de toutes les
convoitises de tous les désirs de toutes
les
préoccupations on s'en préoccupe pas
beaucoup on nous parle du désir d'enfant
du besoin d'enfant de la nécessaire
possibilité d'accéder à une procréation
médicalement
assistée la stérilité c'est quelque
chose d'impossible c'est comme une une
forme de
cessité reproductive euh que plus
personne n'admet moi je veux bien mais
l'intérêt de l'enfant quand on me parle
de l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant je
m'aperçois que c'est une espèce de fourt
qui comprend en réalité tout ce qu'on a
envie d'y mettre mais rien qu' ne soit
vraiment dans la ligne de l'intérêt
spécifique et exclusif de l'enfant je
m'explique lorsque une femme et je
reviens sur le problème des recherche
paternité lorsqu'une femme est enceinte
euh elle d'abord elle le père sera père
quand la mère le décide que ce soit dans
le mariage ou hors mariage parce que
tout nous savons tous que les systèmes
de contraception sont occultes donc le
mari ne peut ne pas savoir si sa femme
prend une contraception quel qu'elle
soit deuxièmement l'avortement on n pas
besoin des deux pour le décider ce qui
veut dire que l'interruption de
grossesse c'est un acte unilatéralement
décidé par la
mer l'enfant qui va naître donc du désir
unilatéral d'une femme parce que c'est
de plus en plus comme ça est un enfant
pour lequel on va pouvoir agir en
recherche de paternité et quand on agit
en recherche de paternité on agit
toujours au nom de l'intérêt de l'enfant
et depuis je n'ose pas dire combien
d'années mais quelques 25 années au
moins si ce ne sont 30 je me bat pour
faire reconnaître un principe de
responsabilité quasi délictu
pour avoir un euro symbolique parce que
j'estime que en 2013 et quelques années
avant d'ailleurs depuis 1967 ou 8 où la
contraception s'est
répandue on ne peut pas être enceinte
malgré soi ou en tout cas le demeurer
malgré soi donc au nom de l'intérêt
supérieur de l'enfant je suis
régulièrement débouté de mes demandes de
dommage intérêt parce que on me dit que
l'enfant a besoin d'avoir un père il a
besoin d'avoir une filiation il a besoin
d'avoir un accès à ses origines peut-on
soutenir dans la main droite des
conclusions au nom de l'intérêt
supérieur de l'enfant ainsi et dans la
main gauche avoir des adoptions
pléniaires qui sont un mensonge
juridique et judiciaire et qui procèdent
à une éradication légale de tout accès
aux origines c'est c'est vraiment une
question qui est tellement choquante ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que là
maintenant on va voir des mariages
homosexuels
ou où il y a forcément un mensonge
quelque part ou un silence gardé quelque
part un mensonge si on ne veut pas dire
ou un silence garder ça revient au même
ça veut dire que ceux qui auront 30 ans
dans 30 ans et qui seront nés dans ces
conditions là est-ce que quelqu'un ici
peut dire ce qui sera son trouble dans
cette inaccessibilité à ses origines je
crois que personne ne peut le dire
personne ne peut dire si ça sera un
trouble ou pas un trouble si ça sera un
droit une revendication personne ne peut
le dire je crois que là nous nous nous
sommes en train de construire une espèce
de
monstruosité et que ce qu'il faut
vraiment réformer c'est l'affiliation on
est dans une société qui prône la
transparence c'est une société qui ne
permet plus le mensonge parce que
effectivement les tests génétiques nous
établissent les paternités les liens de
filiation
99,99 % de sécurité de certitude si on
est dans un système comme celui-là et si
on est est transparent il faut
bouleverser laaffiliation et dire qu'on
va faire coexister pacifiquement parce
que la loi va le penser une filiation
qui sera une filiation
biologique qui sera ou qui ne sera pas
pourvue de conséquence selon que
l'auteur biologique aura décidé
d'assumer sa cette filiation ou de ne
pas l'assumer de la répudier et on aura
parallèlement une filiation élective qui
sera de l'adoption simple ou de
l'adoption de l'adoption simple j'espère
pour ma part que l'adoption pliniiaire
disparaîtra parce que dans ma clientèle
vous posiez la question de ce que nous
voyons dans notre clientèle donc dans ma
clientèle ça fait 32 ans que je suis
avocat et j'ai été 8 ans que l'air de
notaire donc ça fait 40 ans de bons
éloyé au service au droits de la famille
ce que j'ai vu surtout ce sont des
adultes qui sont dans un état de
détresse absolu parce qu'ils n'ont pas
accès à leurs origines et que quand vous
voulez faire un changement de régime
matrimonial euh qui est soumis à une
homologation judiciaire parce qu'il y a
encore un enfant mineur ou autre si cet
enfant est un enfant qui a été adopté en
la forme de l'adoption plinière moi
avocat je ne peux pas obtenir la copie
intégrale de son acte de naissance je ne
peux avoir que des extraits d'actes de
naissance je suis obligé régulièrement
d'avoir accès à la Chancellerie pour me
faire délivrer une pièce que le tribunal
exige pourquoi parce qu'effectivement il
y a la mention sur l'origine du le le
certificat l'acte de naissance d'origine
il y a l'histoire la la véritable
histoire de cet enfant donc je crois que
là cette ce mensonge juridique et
judiciaire n'est plus possible en 2013
il faut vraiment repenser l'affiliation
c'est je crois que c'est pas si
compliqué que de dire il y a une
filiation biologique elle est là il y a
une filiation élective c'est un choix
elle sera cette filiation élective
irréversible et on fait une adoption sa
simple qui sera une adoption simple sans
réversibilité possible et on aura la
vérité la transparence si un jour
l'enfant veut aller voir son géniteur ou
sa génitrice biologique mais il est r
mais il faut quand même arrêter de
reproduire et de faire reproduire pour
satisfaire le besoin des adultes sans
avoir en aucune façon considération des
besoins des enfants alors quant aux
conséquences des divorces et des
ruptures pour répondre à votre question
monsieur ce que nous voyons évidemment
c'est que les humains sont
extraordinaires de la même façon que
quand ils se marient sur le régime de la
séparation de bien la première chose
qu'ils font c'est l'ouverture d'un
conjoint et un achat en indivision et
que quand ils se marient sur le régime
de la communauté ils vont vite chacun
mettre les cadeaux de leurs
grands-parents sans dé livvrer de Caisse
d'Épargne ils sont très surpris de
savoir que l'autre va avoir s'il garde
pas des traces extraordinaires droit à
la moitié de la même façon je vois dans
ma clientèle des concubines qui sont
restés 20 ans avec leur partenaire et
qui viennent me dire mais enfin je
comprends pas on a habité dans mon
appartement c'était mon bien euh j'ai
acheté la nourriture tous les jours et
là maintenant
euh mon partenaire a décidé de partir et
j'ai droit à rien ah non parce que vous
êtes en dehors de la loi et que vous
êtes en concubinage vous n'êtes pas dans
un mariage ou mais enfin quand même ça
fait 20 ans ça fait 20 ans ça pourrait
en faire 50 c'est ainsi alors al on a
exactement dans ces conséquences là les
mêmes la même anarchie intellectuelle
que pour les régimes matrimoniaux à
savoir que les gens se mettent dans des
systèmes de concubinage ou de Pax à
raison de la facilité consubstantielle
de ces modes de
conjugalité pour en sortir sans
procédure sans sans sommation
respectueuse préalable mais au moment où
il faut mesurer supporter les
conséquences de la rupture là plus
personne n'est d'accord et tout le monde
en appel au mariage et à ces
conséquences qui sont quand même un peu
protectrices c'est-à-dire qu'on veut des
droits et on veut aucune obligation donc
je crois que là il y a aussi puisqu'on
est en train de d'ouvrir le mariage à
tous qui est effectivement une avancée
sociale
euh ouvrons aussi l'information à tous
et je crois que l'information c'est pas
dans les 5 minutes qui célèbrprès la
la célébration du mariage le
l'information elle passe par l'éducation
c'est dans les sciences de la vie ou
dans les sciences social avant le
baccalauréat qu'il faut quand même dire
aux gens que quand on se marie ça veut
dire que on va avoir des droits et des
devoirs et ces devoirs ils vont perdurer
sous une forme ou une autre au moment
d'une rupture on prépare pas les gens au
mariage en leur lant l'article 212 et
l'article 215 le jour de la célébration
ils n' ont cure ça leur est complètement
indifférent et les régimes matrimoniaux
c'est la même chose chose on je pense
que toutes ces personnes qui veulent se
marier maintenant et qui sont des
personnes homosexuelles je crois que
c'est très important de leur faire
mesurer je l'ai fait récemment un jeune
homme qui voulait se marier en l'espèce
c'était un jeune français qui voulait se
marier en Espagne avec son compagnon je
lui a dis attention vous vous connaissez
peu il faut quand même savoir qu'en cas
de rupture faudra peut-être payer une
pension alimentaire il a pris comme
disait le mauvais auteur son chapeau et
la fuite voyez donc je crois que c'est
un c'est ce sont des choses qu'il faut
euh vraiment euh il y a une
information dont le législateur ne peut
pas faire l'économie dans un tournant de
l'organisation sociale aussi important
voilà merci Madame CLIS reprendre
oui je je voulais simplement revenir un
tout petit peu sur ce droit aux origines
parce que je crois qu'effectivement il
va falloir que la loi définisse très
précisément qu'est-ce que c'est que le
droit aux origines et et c'est quoi les
origines et c'est quoi l'histoire
pardonnez-moi mais un spermatozoïde ou
un nevocyte c'est pas l'histoire d'un
enfant par contre qu'il soit né par
procréation médicalement assistée c'est
son histoire cette fois-ci donc je pense
que là il faut il faut vraiment regarder
ça de de très très près parce que je
réitère un spermatozoï un nouveau site
c'est un bout du matériel génétique
c'est un bout des chromosomes certes ce
sont des caractères physiques médicaux
et tout ce que l'on voudra certes mais
même sur les caractères physiques c'est
pas entièrement suffisant pour
déterminer quelqu'un euh l'environnement
et cetera joue énormément donc pour moi
que que que toute personne ait accès aux
caractéristiques physiques médicales et
cetera de ces deux parents pas seulement
du père de ces deux parents parce qu'il
y aura aussi avec la PMA des dons de
vosite c'est c'est une chose et c'est
inaliinable je crois vraiment qu'il faut
que la loi le définisse très précisément
c'est ce que je voulais dire un peu tout
à l'heure quand je disais attention
aussi au droit entre guillemets du
donneur il faut que l'on sache quelles
informations seront devront être données
à l'enfant qui effectivement doit rester
vraiment au centre de nos préoccupations
et je pense que s'il y a bien quelque
chose de dangereux que l'on est en train
de faire en ce moment et là c'est la
scientifique ex scientifique qui parle
ce sont les manipulations de gamèes je
dis bien les manipulations de gamèes que
l'on fait en amont des fécondations
éitrro ça c'est extrêmement dangereux
sur un plan scientifique là on ne sait
pas du tout où l'on va et là je pense
qu'il faut être très prudent par par
contre sur les origines je pense que la
loi peut sans aucun problème
sereinement bien fixer les choses et
bien fixer le cadre dans l'intérêt
supérieur de
l'enfant pardon mais je pense qu'on je
crois que c'est un peu réducteur de
considérer un spermatozoïde et un ovule
comme du matériel génétique c'est pas
seulement du matériel génétique parce
que si c'était seulement du matériel
génétique vous n'auriez pas et je
pourrais vous les faire
rencontrer les personnes qui sont en
état de souffrance pour savoir qui était
leur leur donneur de spermatozoïdes qui
était le porteur du spermatozoïde qui
les a
engendré je pense que un humain je je
crois qu'il est très très difficile et
qui serait un peu
euh un peu téméraire de notre part de
décider de ce qui sera bon pour tous euh
dans 30 ans ou dans 50 ans je suis pas
du tout convaincu que celui qui sera né
n'aura pas envie de savoir qui était le
porteur du matériel génétique et n'aura
pas envie d'avoir des liens avec ce
porteur de matériel génétique les
psychanalystes excusez-moi les
psychanalystes qu'on a écouté sur le
sujet nous disent que généralement ces
demande quand elles deviennent
pathologiques sont lié à des problèmes
présents et non pas forcément des
problèmes passés donc je pense que c'est
sur ce que vous appeliez le mensonge
tout à l'heure et là je vous je vous
suis sur ce mensonge de l'origine de la
naissance qui a sans doute des choses à
VO mais
bon sur ce point madame Virginie on va
entendre tout à l'heure le Président
tunaop on pourra poser toutes les
questions mais je crois qu'on est assez
d'accord ici en tout cas moi c'est mon
point de vue pour dire que quel que soit
le mode d'engendrement d'un enfant cet
enfant doit pouvoir connaître son
histoire voilà alors ensuite ensuite bon
je vais donner la parole à Maître denoî
encore ensuite
maître maître Leclerc poiv pas je vois
que là il y a que des doubles noms donc
c'est très bien comme dans la loi voilà
donc
oui nous
avons entendu ici des professeurs de
droit alors je parlerai pas de celui ou
ceux qui étaient favorable au
texte j'étais assez impressionné parce
que je le connaissais depuis 15 ans par
le témoignage du professeur Roser qui
était professeur à Bordeaux qui au
moment du Pax militait plutôt pour une
union civile et cetera et qui maintenant
nous dit euh les pouvoirs avoir le
courage exactement ce que vous avez dit
d'établir un texte qui reconnaisse les
deux lignes de filiation voilà pour tous
les couples ou pour les femmes seules
une filiation biologique bon voilà et
puis une filiation volontaire sociale
vous avez un autre adjectif moi j'ai dit
élective vous avez dit élective voilà et
qu'on et qu'on sache très bien où on va
et euh alors bon ici tout le monde n'est
pas d'acord accord loin de là euh loin
de là même parmi les socialistes mais
même ooser nous dit vous devrait aborder
toutes les façons et encore comme vous
les aurez abordé dans la loi il est
possible que dans 10 ou 20 ans il y en
encore d'autres voilà donc on en est là
voilà alors c'est peut-être un gouffre
pour certains mais moi je suis heureux
de vous entendre par rapport euh à votre
cliantelle enfin au aux faits concrets
que vous connaissez et cetera voilà
enfin bon après he débat peut-être que
Madame Denois veut ajouter quelque
chose mais écoutez pas forcément ce qu'a
dit une FO Lecler à balayé un peu
l'ensemble des sujets mais c'est vrai
que encore une fois on est tous très
demandeur d'une d'une réforme de
l'affiliation et c'est vrai que je on
est très nombreux à partager ce point
sur le le la question de la révocabilité
de la de l'adoption aujourd'hui qui qui
est devenu complètement hors de propos
oui et et et et aussi de l'adoption
plinièire qui tel qu' aujourd'hui ne
répond pas à ce qu'elle est vraiment
voilà et ça tout le monde le sait parce
que l'adoption plinière elle a été faite
à un moment où on aé des bébés des bébés
des bébés blancs pour les blancs voilà
et
qu'aujourd'hui on voit bien qui on peut
adopter alors si on a la chance dans un
département où il y a
quelques quelques enfants à la à la ceux
qui sont adoptables on peut avoir cette
chance sinon on va à l'étranger alors là
on ramène un petit garçon une petite
fille quelquefois même un adolescent qui
forcément je sais pas si on nous a dit
l'autre jour mais il comprend pas je
pense que si je pense qu'il comprend il
comprend que il est pas pareil que ses
parents quand même non je sais pas moi
s'il vient du Vietnam ou de du Mali ou
du Brésil ou du bon voilà donc ça
correspond plus à la réalité quoi voilà
et je j'ai été très impressionné par un
psychanalyste dont je ne citerai pas le
nom ici qui lui est toujours accroché à
euh l'adoption pliniiaire telle qu'elle
est et qui nous dit euh l'adoption
pliniiaire c'est la rupture
totale avec la famille d'origine
l'enfant rentre dans le lit de ses
parents par le haut il en ressort par le
fond c'est fini il est l'enfant cette
famille bon enfin j'ajoute j'ajoute pas
bon alors voilà est-ce que vous avez
quelque chose à ajouter mesdames maître
non n remercions pour vos témoignages
concrets et euh passer s'ils sont
arrivés ou il y a encore 2 3 minutes ça
permettra à certains de se dégourdir les
gens au Conseil national des
d'action euh mes chers collègues si vous
voulez
bien reprendre
place donc nous avons aujourd'hui notre
3e
séquence avec
le Conseil national d'accès aux origines
personnelles je remercie son président
Monsieur nut que tout le monde connaît
et le secrétaire général monsieur
Chabrol de bien vouloir venir nous avons
encore à l'instant évoqué ce problème
des
origine qui est posé par ce texte enfin
qui sera encore plus posé par un
texte sur la famille sur l'adoption mais
qui tout de
même est quand même posé dans ce Tex
notamment en ce qui concerne les
adoption plinière par les coupes de même
sexe voilà donc je vais vous donner la
parole pendant euh enfin on a une heure
en tout
voilà pour répondre àprès des
questions monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs et
sénatrices euh je vais donc dans un
premier temps avec votre accord euh vous
présenter très
rapidement la loi du de janvier 2002
évoquer à cette occasion les activités
du knnaop
euh et ensuite on évoquera un certain
nombre de points particuliers et on
répondra à vos questions bien entendu
monsieur le rapporteur alors je dirais
que ce texte de du 22 janvier 2002 c'est
un texte qui a disons des des qualités
incontestable c'est un texte qui a remis
si vous voulez en cohérence un certain
nombre de dispositifs p et c'est
manifestement un texte de progrès on
rappellera que ce texte avait été voté à
l'unanimité par les deux chambres et on
rappellera aussi que ce texte a
maintenant 10 ans et que mon dieu il
commence à se stabiliser il doit
certainement évoluer mais en tout cas
c'est un texte qui qui maintenant
commence à à être établi avec des
jurisprudences nécessaires et comm il si
à de loi
d'ailleurs je dirais que on rappellera
aussi utilement que le Sénat en 2007
avait introduit une
disposition qui consistait à dire que
l'accès aux origines pouvait bien
entendu était ouvert bien entendu des
l'instants où l'enfant avait ou l'adulte
maintenant l'adulte avait atteint ses 18
ans mais également la possibilité de
descendre en dessous de cette limite
lorsque l'enfant avait le discernement
nécessaire donc ça c'était une
disposition qui n'a certes pas
encore de disposition j'allais dire
opérationnelle mais qui a quand même
lancé à mon
avis un signal et que nous retrouverons
certainement dans le débat sur la
recherche des origines sur le sujet qui
nous préoccupe ce
matin pour faire simple cette loi c'est
deux parties première partie c'est le
droit à accoucher dans le
secret on appelle ça plus communément
l'accouchement sous
X deuxème partie c'est l'accès au ses
origines c'est-à-dire la possibilité
pour ces personnes qui sont nées sous X
de pouvoir un jour à 18 ans en principe
ou à partir de 18 ans accéder à ses
origines le knaop dans toute cette dans
ce dispositif législatif a notamment
notamment pour obchet c'est la loi qui
l'indique de facilité de faciliter
l'accès à ses origines
personnelles on va donner tout de suite
deux trois chiffres on va pas on va pas
vous abreuver de statistiques parce que
on les oublie tout de suite
euh on a à peu près pas à peu près hein
600 600 enfants qui
qui naissent sous le secret dans notre
pays c'est un chiffre qui est constant
qui est par an
constant ce chiffre a très sensiblement
diminué pour des raisons d'évidence et
notamment après lesill où l'avortement a
permis j'allais dire de régler un
certain nombre de situation donc 600
enfants et depuis que le kn existe on a
eu 7000 demandes 7000 demandes d'accès
aux origines
7000 demandes utiles autrement dit je
veux dire par là que certains
administrés nous nous écrivent en disant
je me suis brouillé avec ma mère il y a
20 ans j'aimerais bien la retrouver
pouvez-vous m'aider bon donc ce sont des
demandes qui ne sont pas négligeables he
faut bien voir que les gens nous
écrivent pour des tas de choses ou bien
ma mère ne trouve plus l'adresse de mon
père pourriez vous voilà donc là ce sont
des demandes auxquelles on répond bien
sûr mais qui n'entrent pas dans le
alors on va maintenant décomposer en
deux parties d'une part l'accouchement
sous le
secret c'est d'abord une décision de la
mère de naissance c'est une décision qui
lui appartient c'est une décision
qu'elle n'a pas à justifier autrement
dit la personne se présente à la
maternité
elle peut y venir avant enfin tout ce
que on veut elle n'a pas à décliner son
identité
elle n'a pas à décliner son identité
elle n'a pas à évoquer les conditions
qui l'ont amené à prendre cette
décision et les
l'administration l'administration n'a
pas à investiguer autrement dit on est
sur un déclaratif strict
euh parce que nous sommes dans une
situation secret et pour que ce secret
soit bien gardé et bien dès lors par
exemple la prise en charge des frais
d'accouchement des frais
d'hospitalisation sont pris en charge
par l'État donc en tout cas
nous nous au niveau du knaop on n'a pas
eu connaissance de cas de violation de
secret et c'est une bonne chose alors ce
qu'il faut bien voir à partir de ce
moment-là et c'est là où on a une
incidence avec le les problèmes qui nous
préoccupent c'est que nous l'oknaop
enfin la loi en tout cas ne prévoit pas
de demander si c'est de la PMA si c'est
de la gestion pour autruit c'est pas le
sujet la personne arrive accouche voilà
bon donc ça c'est c'est vraiment le
premier point donc les droits deuxème
point évidemment euh il appartient au
personnel hospitalier il appartient au
personnel des conseils généraux qui font
un travail remarquable
d'ailleurs de rencontrer la personne de
leur
expliquer dans quel contexte de
juridique elle se situe autrement dit
bien de leur de bien leur expliquer que
si elle décide si elle persiste dans
leur décision et bien on ira vers un
processus d'adoption avec tout ce que
cela porte autrement dit l'adoption au
bout de 2 2 mois est
irréversible donc on explique bien ça à
la à la femme qui vient
d'accoucher on lui explique aussi que la
loi a prévu des possibilités qui tout en
maintenant le secret et bien permettront
peut-être un jour de faire en sorte que
l'enfant ainsi pourra avoir des
informations sur ses origines à travers
un système qui s'appelle le pli fermé
alors dans ce pli fermé on peut mettre
qui est é le père on peut mettre des
renseignements sur la santé on peut
mettre tout ce que l'on souhaite on peut
aussi décider de dire bon ben moi
lorsque mon enfant l'enfant que je viens
de porter et bien aura ces 18 ans il
pourra savoir qui je suis bon donc je
dirais que l'action là est est très
importante parce qu'il s'agit à la fois
de ne pas faire pression sur la personne
mais il s'agit surtout de l'éclairer
hein de l'éclairer parce
que nos études montrent que d'une
manière générale ce sont des personnes
qui sont en difficulté hein qui sont en
difficulté sociale disons la grande
majorité d'ailleurs ces personnes
lorsqu'on regarde comment elles se
répartissent à la fois géographiquement
ou à la fois par catégorie
socio-professionnelle on s'aperçoit bien
souvent dans une très grande majorité
qu'on est sur des personnes qui ont de
gros problèmes qui ont de gros problèmes
donc voilà ça il faut faut le prendre en
compte alors pourquoi ces personnes
prennent cette décision qu'est-ce
qu'elles disent qu'est-ce qu'elles
disent qu'est-ce qu'elles ont comme
motivation la première motivation c'est
souvent de dire par exemple et bien
j'étais victime d'un abus sexuel c'est
une des motifs qui est souvent
indiqué il y a aussi des des situations
de dénis autrement dit la personne niait
son état de grossesse et le temps
passant et bien elle était arrivée il y
avait pas d'autre solution dès lors elle
ne souhaitait pas le garder il y a aussi
le compagnon qui apprenant la grossesse
et voyant que celle-ci se poursuit et
bien abandonne sa compagne ça existe
aussi il y a aussi des couples dieu
merci enfin des couples qui de manièreès
rare prennent des
décisions de faire d'accoucher sous X
voilà donc on a une multiplicité de de
situations mais tout ça c'est c'est
c'est quelque chose qui est déclaratif
sur lequel on na pas na pas d'ailleurs à
à chercher plus
mais ce que j'ajouterais aussi c'est que
sur les 600
accouchements faits dans le secret et
bien un tiers à peu près ou un peu moins
d'un tiers des personnes ont eu un
l'idée de contacter des
association avant
l'accouchement l'assistante sociale de
la ville avant l'accouchement donc il y
a eu aussi pour le tiers au moins un
travail pas dire préparatoire mais en
tout cas un cheminement
social qui a a abouti à cette décision
néanmoins
voilà mais
une chose aussi doit être dite c'est que
nous avons le sentiment d'après ce que
nous remonte
nos les conseils généraux que ce sont
d'une manière générale des personnes en
souffrance hein ça faut faut bien noter
si vous voulez ce sont des personnes en
souffrance et c'est pas c'est pas simple
c'est pas simple et je crois que elles
doivent prendre dans des délais très
courts des décisions très rudes hein la
décision
de de ne pas de ne pas prendre l'enfant
et quelque chose qui est lourd de
conséquence c'est au bout de de mois il
y a pas de marche arrière c'est ça qu'il
faut bien voir hein c'est ça qu'il faut
bien
voir
alors dans tout
ça on va passer au second volet hein on
va passer au second volet qui est
l'accès aux origines autrement dit c'est
la possibilité pour la personne qu'il
souhaite et bien
de de pouvoir essayer de retrouver de
retrouver disons les coordonnées de sa
mère de naissance hein alors pourquoi
nous disons mère de naissance c'est
parce que c'est par opposition à la mère
qui a adopté l'enfant et pour nous c'est
quelque chose de très différent c'est un
vocabulaire qui n'est pas neutre hein
donc pour la mère de
naissance alors on a rappelé si vous
vous voulez
que ce droit est ouvert cette
possibilité est ouverte si vous
voulez aux personnes qui ont plus de 18
ans et dans toute la mesure du possible
et si l'enfant le demande et bien et
s'il a le discernement nécessaire aux
enfant aux personnes qui ont moins de 18
ans le premier point c'est une
caractéristique qui ne simplifie pas les
choses c'est que l'âge moyen l'âge moyen
si vous voulez
de des personnes qui font une demande
d'accès aux origines c'est pas il y a
pas un rush à 18 ans faut pas croire
qu'à 18 ans la plupart des personnes qui
sont nées sous X et qui le savent parce
que nous pourrions vous dire que
certaines personnes ne savent pas à 18
ans qu'elles ont été adoptées nous avons
des dossiers où certaines personnes le
savent à 60 ans bon donc oui oui ça
c'est quand même c'est c'est quand même
des choses qui qu'il faut savoir donc
ces personnes disons il faut savoir que
nos
dossiers ce sont des dossiers qui ont au
minimum 30
ans 30 ans et plus la majorité de nos
dossiers un dossier sur de c'est 30 ans
et plus puisque l'âge
moyen de recherche des origines et bien
c'est largement au-dessus de 30 ans donc
pour l'administ tion avoir un dossier
qui a non pas sommeillé mais qui a été
classé depuis 30 ans c'est quelque chose
qui est pas simple et là on s'aperçoit
que quand vous regardez les dossiers qui
ont ces âges là l'informatique
n'existait pas on est sur du manuel on
est sur des pratiques diverses et
variées bon donc c'est pas quelque chose
de facile he c'est pas quelque chose de
facile ça c'est le premier point le
deuxème point c'est que il découle un
peu du premier c'est c'est que
pratiquement pour un peu moins d'une
demande sur deux nous ne retrouvons pas
la personne on retrouve pas la maman la
mère de naissance alors on la retrouve
pas bah c'est assez normal parce que 30
ans 40 ans après ben la personne a pu
déménager et on ne voit pas comment
imposer à cette à cette mère de
naissance de d'indiquer à une autorité
administrative quelconque leur
changement de résidence ça ça n'est pas
concevable hein bon donc plus presque un
dossier sur deux on ne sait pas
retrouver la personne et alors ça c'est
très frustrant vous comprenez parce que
la personne qui cherche ses origines euh
soit nous fait à l'administration en
général un procès d'incompétence en
disant oui vous ne mettez pas la bonne
volonté euh telle association explique
que bien évidemment si elle avait
l'affaire elle trouverait mais voilà
donc ça c'est le premer point euh 2è
point si vous voulez c'est que donc
moins d'un dossier sur deux à une fin
heureuse et pratiquement après on arrive
à satisfaire entre guillemets 30 %. 30 %
alors les autres on n'y arrive pas parce
que soit la mère maintient le refus hein
en la enfin la mè est identifié nous la
contactons et elle maintient son refuse
qui est son droit c'est prévu hein soit
elle prétend que la personne que nous
contactons qu'elle n'a jamais été maèire
de naissance de qui que ce soit bon mais
en tout cas on a j'allais dire un un
taux de succès qui n'est pas j'allais
dire qui pourrait de l'extérieur tout ou
moins ne pas être considéré comme
performant mais je veux dire que dès
lors où on travaille sur des dossiers en
moyenne qui ont 40 ans c'est
difficile ce qu'il faut aussi voir c'est
que
euh la demande des personnes en
recherche de leur mère de naissance
n'est pas uniforme autrement dit
certains ont l'adresse de leur enfin ont
le nom de leur mère de naissance sa date
de son lieu de
naissance ça leur
suffit d'autres souhaitent aller plus
loin autrement dit rencontrer la mère de
naissance là je dirais c'est une étape
de plus bon mais rencontrer la mère de
naissance sans pour autant
envisager de nouer des relations
pérennes on a aussi des des situations
enfin on en a vécu il y a pas très
longtemps assez assez rudes c'est que
par
exemple la personne avait retrouvé sa
mère de naissance
et le contact s'est mal passé parce
que parce que cette personne avait
acquis un certain niveau de vie et
cetera que sa maman sa mère de naissance
n'avait pas acquis du tout le même
niveau de vie et vraiment il a pas
compris bon donc on est sur une un
système où manifestement c'est du pas à
la carte je dirais pas jusque- là mais
c'est pas une demande uniforme égale
dans son contenu hein ça c'est c'est pas
c'est pas vrai si vous voulez
et donc là-dessus nous ce que nous
pensons et nous ne sommes pas le seuls à
le penser les associations qui comp
pose le Conseil national sont convaincus
qu'un accompagnement serait nécessaire
un accompagnement jeis
dire très professionnel serait
nécessaire pour que ce demandeur et bien
soit pas facee un cheminement quoi hein
bon voilà donc ça si vous voulez c'est
c'est un peu cette recherche bon il est
clair qu'avec les fichiers informatiques
on peut croiser on augmente les
performances mais il y a une limite
qu'on ne franchira
jamais je voudrais aborder
maintenant le le problème disons de la
reconnaissance de la parentalité par
les par les Pères tout simplement hein
bon
lorsqu'une femme accouche sous X rien
n'interdit rien interdit à un homme de
faire une demande de parentalité ou de
se déclarer en parentalité c'est c'est
le texte on a une circulaire si vous
voulez qui reprend une loi bien sûr du
ministère de la Justice hein c'est la
circulaire du 28 octobre 2011 qui permet
euh qui traite expressément
d'ailleurs les accouchements sous X et
qui permet d'accéder à la parentalité
sur
une sur une demande du père assez simple
en définitive puisque déclaration de
parentalité devant le maire et puis
après le céant devant le
procureur il est clair que lorsqu'on
évoque cette possibilité juridique euh
on peut peut penser notamment à la
gestation pour
autruit faut faut dire les choses
simplement hein alors nous en l'état
actuel de nos connaissances en l'état
actuel de nos
connaissances nous n'avons pas perçu
nous avavons pas identifié de telles
situation voyez bien la la prudence de
mon
propos le secrétaire général vous dirait
qu'on a à peu près moins d'une dizaine
de cas 10 cas où il y a eu demande de
reconnaissance de
parentalité bon donc je veux dire que
c'est pas avec 10 on fait une règle et
surtout que c'est pas 10k concentré hein
c'est 10k au cours des dernières années
et certains cas nous semble
particulièrement net nette du point de
vue disons de la gestion pour autrui euh
gestation pour autru pardon par exemple
mais ça on n pas jugé hein c'est un
couple
marié avec deux enfants déjà enfin deux
enfants ils ont deux enfants
et donc la mère de naissance bon madame
est enceinte la mère de naissance dit
moi je veux accoucher sous X bon et le
mari dit mais moi je je reconnais la
parentalité par avance et après
cetteodame ajoute comme nous sommes dans
une en dans un
département petite taille ajoute qu'elle
ne veut pas accoucher dans ce
département bon comprenent qu' pourra
mais on est sur quelque chose qui me
semble très loin de la gestion de la
gestation pour
autrui bon donc il y a Mar n pas
lere monsieur le rapporteur on n pas été
si loin enfin il y a des choses mais ça
doit être ça à mon avis ça doit être ça
et puis puis voilà bon mais ça existe on
n' pas jugé on n pas jugé c'est c'est
comme ça voilà
donc c'est une chose deuxième élément
qui nous conforte peut-être c'est que
on est à peu près sur 600
accouchements 600 accouchements sous le
secret parent comme je vous l'indiqué en
propos
liminire ce qui est une diminution
faible mais évidente par rapport au
nombre de naissances constaté au cours
des dernières années donc on ne peut pas
parler si vous voulez de de déviation
combien même on peut pas parler de ce
sujet on peut simplement dire que c'est
une c'est une possibilit ité enfin en
tout cas que juridiquement c'est quelque
chose qui
existe juridiquement c'est quelque chose
qui existe le secret étant ce qu'il est
mais moi je ne fais pas partie de ceux
qui pensent que je pense qu'il faut
surtout voir ce que les choses vont
donner est-ce que les évolution vont
donner si on a une rupture de courbe
dans les déclarations de d'accouchement
sous X on
verra voilà donc je voulais vous dire
cela et je voulais pour pour
terminer évoquer un sujet je sais pas si
il est dans les brisés du knop à
l'évidence mais fait partie dans S plus
large ce qui me préoccupe le plus avec
le secrétaire général
c'est ce sont ces enfants qui déjà sont
élevés par des
familles de même sexe si vous voulez
hein ce sont des enfants alors les
chiffres j'ai pas trouvé de statistique
bien établi là-dessus l'INED parle d'un
maximum de
40000 tout en mettant le plancher vers
euh certaines associations parlent
plutôt de une ou deux centaines de m000
mais il me semble clair si vous voulez
que on ne peut pas
se se désintéresser si vous voulez de
ces enfants hein et on ne peut pas ne
pas avoir le souci de leur donner un
cadre juridique familial peut-être plus
établi on ne peut pas non plus on ne
peut pas non plus se désintéresser
totalement même totalement est un peu
excessive d'ailleurs on peut pas se
désintéresser tout court j'allais dire
de l'accès aux origines qu'ils auront
qu'ils souhaiteront un jour avoir parce
que à la différence si vous voulez des
enfants qui sont dans une famille dont
le père et la mère sont de sexes
différents très vite très
vite dès aujourd'hui d'ailleurs très
vite dès aujourd'hui l'enfant va se
préoccuper de savoir qui il est d'où il
vient hein donc là je pense si vous
voulez
que c'est pour moi un sujet c'est pour
moi un sujet parce que je suis convaincu
aussi que l'évolution notre société est
telle que le droit de savoir est quelque
chose qui se qui est de plus en plus
fort si vous voulez aujourd'hui on a
c'est normal qu'on sache si vous voulez
dans tous les domaines et je dirais que
là-dessus on peut pas être en décalage
peut pas être en décalage si vous
voulez avec des phénomènes aussi forts
que de société bon donc voilà moi c'est
une interrogation l'interrogation est
que j'ai regardé qu'est-ce qu'il y avait
comme étude disponible sur ces familles
sur ces enfants je n'en ai pas trouvé
mais c'est peut-être parce que j'ai pas
assez cherché mais là-dessus il faut
vraiment que on regarde ce problème
parce que en tout état de cause je pense
que ça ne peut que se développer avec ou
sans texte d'ailleurs voilà voilà
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames
messieurs ce que je souhaitais vous dire
en propos
et maintenant le secrétaire général et
moi-même nous efforcerons de répondre à
vos questions merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président pour ce témoignage plein de
d'humanité de pragmatisme alors moi
juste une question à vous poser mes ça
je devrais le
savoir lorsqu'une mère femme vient
accoucher chous X elle n'est pas obligée
de laisser un P
fermé
d'accord donc elle peut tout donc dans
ces cas-là évidemment toute recherche et
vous à
l'échec pratiquement enfin bon d'accord
donc ça c'est la vous avez répondu à
cette question là donc voilà alors
ensuite comme vous l'avez dit et ça a
été dit tout au long des auditions c'est
vrai
qu'aujourd'hui le droit de savoir voilà
c'est comme ça la
transparence donc ce problème se pose
aussi pour les enfants qui recherchent
leur histoire plus que leur origine
d'ailleurs bon voilà donc ça
existe mais ça va exister ça existe
encore plus déjà dans les enfants qui
vivent un découpement seexuel encore
plus quand ça sera varié euh bon ça
existera alors toute une série de cas
pour lesquels si j'ai bien compris que
vous n'êtes pas compétent donc euh
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il faut d'une
façon ou d'une autre augmenter le champ
de vos compétences car si j'ai bien
compris vous êtes compétent aujourd'hui
uniquement pour les 600 enfants par an
qui naissent sous X en France et et et
ceux qui sont nés avant et oui et ceux
qui sont nés avant mais mais mais cuid
cuid euh des enfants qui viennent de
l'étranger adoption étrangère puisque
maintenant l'adoption pratiquement bon
voilà donc là euh des enfants peuvent
rechercher aensite leurs origines je
dirais premièrement s'ils sont dans un
coup hétérosexuel parce qu'ils
s'aperçoivent rapidement
que bon les qui les ont adopté de façon
plinière peuvent pas être leur parents
biologique parce que donc pas la même
couleur de peau ni rien du tout quand en
plus ça sera un couple de même sexe ça
fera une double interrogation je
suppose voilà donc ces questions nous
ont été posées ici très largement et
certains ont même évoqué je sais plus
céit les associations je crois en disant
mais le knnaop doit pouvoir avoir ses
compétences élargies et doit pouvoir
répondre à toutes ses interrogations
voilà bon mais je vais on va faire un
tour général comme ça vous pour pour
répondre non peut-être répondre tout de
suite à ça et
complètera qu'on peut dire sur seul
rapporteur c'est
que à mon avis tout ce qui est recherche
des origines tenu d'information si vous
voulez qui permettent de d'accéder à ses
origines est quelque chose qui ressort
du domaine de l'État autrement dit c'est
vraiment je pas dire du domaine régalien
c'est un peu fort en tout cas on voit
pas si vous voulez confier ça à une
association c'est trop compliqué bon
alors après moi vous savez je je suis
pas attrape tout comme on ditin je veux
dire que bon le
kn acquis une certaine expérience je
dire en en propos introductif l'organe
de de conseil du Conseil national de par
sa
composition permet si vous voulez des
débats permet remblé donc s'il faut
étendre les compétences du PNA pourquoi
pas mais je veux dire qu'il faut qu'il a
du fond derrière et voilà hein mais
après moi je serions prêt à tout ce que
mais tout ce qu'il faudrait faire mais
je rappelleraai rapporteur que c'est le
domaine de la loi ah tout à
fait donc voilà je veux dire pourquoi
pas mais pas à tout prix si vous voulez
je suis pas ici à chercher de la
charge voilà Monsieur le Secrétaire
général tu si si vous permettez Monsieur
sénateur sur votre première
interrogation concernant le pli fermé ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que donc
évidemment une femme qui vient accoucher
donc dans le secret pour un infime
pourcentage de ces femmes-là viment
infime hein au alentours de 1 ou 2 % de
ce que nous savons sont des femmes qui
ne restent pas la maternité qui
repartent très très vite voir
éventuellement ement 2 he à peine après
avoir accouché en refusant de de signer
toutes décharges de
responsabilité elles partent certaines
fu donc ces femmesl déjà petit
pourcentage mais comme on est sur des
petits nombres les petits pourcentages
sur les petits nombres sont toujours des
faits très significatifs sont des femmes
que ni les correspondants départementaux
ni des professionnels de santé ne
peuvent véritablement
rencontrer parce que la raison
fondamentale de l'accouchement dans le
secret le président vous l'a dit déjà
euh c'est pas
donc le sujet premier de savoir si
quelqu'un peut ou non garder le secret
la raison fondamentale c'est que pour ce
pays-là une femme donc qui vient
accoucher a le droit de ressortir en
bonne santé et l'enfant aussi c'est ça
qui justifie l'accouchement dans le
secret c'est un un sujet sanitaire c'est
un sujet de sécurité de la mère et de
l'enfant il vaut mieux qu'elle accouche
dans une maternité et en prenant le
risque qu'on est pas son identité plutôt
qu'elle aille accoucher je ne sais où
qu'elle en meurt que l'enfant
éventuellement en meurt donc ça il faut
vraiment avoir en tête qu'il y a pas de
débat idéologique très compliqué enfin
sauf si on veut faire de ce sujet de
sécurité un déb idéologique mais ça me
semble personnellement assez éloigné de
la réalité une fois que cette femme donc
a accouché si elle décide de de rester
au moins 48h ou 72h
elle est rencontré par un correspondant
départemental qui est un professionnel
du conseil général si jamais il ne peut
pas être là le directeur de la maternité
a dû s'organiser la loi en fait une
obligation pour qu'un prof essionnel de
santé fasse ce travail auprès de cette
femme et évidemment donc la rencontre se
fait donc sur la base d'un recueil
d'information qui est un recueil qui
relève d'un d'un arrêté ministériel qui
l'organise et qui bord des périmètre
tout ce qu'on peut demander à la femme
mais le premier dialogue si tentz que le
dialogue soit vraiment possible que
cette femme-là entre donc dans une
démarche de dialogue c'est de lui dire
il est important pour l'enfant que il
sache un certain nombre de choses et
vous avez madame plusieurs possibilités
la première vous avez le droit de ne
rien dire si vous dites rien on prend
acte que vous ne dites rien la seconde
c'est que vous avez le droit de laisser
tout élément non identifiant vous pouvez
dire que le père était français
américain que vous avez les cheveux
blond que vous avez fait des études
supérieurs pas des études vous laissez
les éléments non identifiants parce que
donc dans l'histoire de l'enfant c'est
important qu'il ait au moins ces
éléments là et si vous voulez en dire
plus alors vous avez plusieurs
possibilités pour le faire la première
possibilité c'est que vous avez le droit
dans le délai de 2 mois qui sépare
l'accouchement donc de l'engagement du
processus d'adoption de reconnaître
l'enfant vous faites une reconnaissance
d'enfant comme tout personne fait une
reconnaissance en France si vous faites
une reconnaissance donc d'enfant deux
voix vous sont ouvertes madame la
première c'est que vous pouvez décider
de ne pas élever l'enfant et de le
confier au conseil général vous l'avez
reconnu il entre dans un processus
d'adoption la seconde voix c'est vous
avez reconnu l'enfant et vous en
demandez la restitution sous réserve qu'
a pas de problème majeur de protection
de l'enfance votre droit c'est de
repartir avec cet enfant-là si donc vous
l'avez reconnu et que vous l'avez confié
en signant procèsverbal d'abandon
monsieur le sénateur si vous l'avez fait
évidemment l'enfant aura droit donc à la
connaissance de l'identité de votre de
vous-même madame c'est parfaitement
clair deuxième étape si vous voulez pas
faire ça vous avez le droit de laisser
votre identité dans le dossier non
secrète si l'enfant demande à y accéder
on lui donnera donc votre identité trème
étape vous avez l'étape du pli fermé
c'est vous qui donc on vous donne une
enveloppe un peu officielle élaborée
fait par les conseil généraux vous y
mettez ce que vous souhaitez évidemment
ce qu'on vous explique c'est que si vous
y mettez votre identité c'est mieux mais
enfin vous c'est vous qui met qui
écrirez ce que vous voulez écrire on ne
relit pas c'est vous qui mettrez ceci
dans l'enveloppe c'est vous qui fermerez
l'enveloppe nous simplement conseil
général on est gardien de cette
enveloppe là on ne l'ouvre pas ce n'est
que si l'enfant demande à accéder à ses
origines que le un membre du knaop en
l'occurrence probablement le président
puisqu'on n pas pour l'instant reçu de
demandes de ce type là l'ouvrira s'il
ouvre et s'il y a une identité alors on
cherchera à vous contacter si on vous
retrouve enfin il faut dire que la loi
nous a donné des moyens d'investigation
très considérable notamment auprès des
organismes de protection et monsieur le
sénateur il vous a S pas échapper qu'il
y a peu de citoyens en France qui sont
pas concernés par un régime de
protection sociale donc on arrive assez
facilement à retrouver si donc on vous
retrouve alors à ce moment-là vous
pourrez dire oui c'est bien moi qui ai
laissé mais là au moment où vous m'en
parlez je suis pas prête à lever le
secret donc je vous demande de ne rien
dire mais on pourra revoir cette
démarche ultérieurement ou effectivement
c'est bien moi et je suis prêt donc à
lever le secret donc il y a voyez fa une
sorte de panel sur cet aspect des choses
pour ce qui est des enfants nés à
l'étranger la compétence du knop est
très stricte monsieur le sénateur est
très stricte parce que elle ne concerne
que soit des enfants d'abord un
premièrement des enfants qui sont nés
dans le secret ça c'est une première
condition deuxième condition la
législation a beaucoup évolué entre 1904
et
1996 en France il y a eu des périodes où
même si la mère n'avait pas accouché
dans le secret les parents jusqu'à l'âge
de 7 ans de l'enfant pouvait donc
confier à l'adoption leur enfant puis
ensuite tout ceci est diminué maintenant
on est dans le délai de 2 mois qui a
prévu la loi de 2002 donc on a des
situations assez diverses de ce point de
vue-là donc ça veut dire que donc que
une femme a pu ne pas avoir accouché
dans le secret il y a très longtemps
confieré avant que l'enfant a 7 ans cet
enfant à l'adoption notamment auprès du
Conseil Général nous sommes à ce
moment-là compétents voilà pour les
auditions de la commission des Lois du
Sénat sur le mariage pour tous si vous
souhaitez les revoir elles sont
disponibles en VOD sur notre site
internet
publicsena.fr prochain rendez-vous avec
les travaux parlementaires c'est cet
après-midi à partir de 15h avec les
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement
bonne journée à
tous